President Joe Biden with a bold and
Powerful statement said he had two words
and then he said three and that's it and
it was hilarious and it's just I don't
even know how you make just a stupid
mistake but we're gonna play the video
and then we're all gonna laugh because
it's Friday and everybody needs a good
laugh and because it's Friday as well
it's time to end this week with um
something a little bit more relaxing I
mean obviously we are going to talk
about the apocalypse in World War Three
but we're gonna make jokes about it
we're gonna make fun of Joe Biden
because his brain doesn't work we've
also got probably one of the most epic
responses in cancel culture history Matt
Walsh many left a seven spreading around
these out of context Clips trying to
smear him and make accusations against
him so he just issued the most epic
response ever where he was just like
kiss my ass you should be apologizing to
me and that I can't even do it justice
it's so good and so we'll talk about
that plus we do have some pretty crazy
stories really dark stuff Corey Bush
she's a progressive Democrat
an interview came out on on PBS
where she told the story of where she
underwent a she was the victim of a
forced abortion where she begged them to
stop and they wouldn't and it's just
like dude this story is like it's like a
Horror Story man so we'll talk about
that before we get started my friends
head over to timcast.com and become a
member in order to support our work as a
member you'll get access to exclusive
segments from the timcast IRL uncensored
show Monday through Thursday at 11 PM
those are all up from this week we're
gonna be chilling tonight but you'll
also get to watch the cast Castle Vlog
which you're gonna get a kick out of
we've got a fun episode coming up next
Tuesday you got to watch the whole Civil
War Arc there's like an election and
then bounce coming at 3 A.M and then
people are fighting you don't want to
miss it but I'm really excited for what
we're filming next week which will be
not this coming Tuesday but the Tuesday
after is probably going to be extremely
offensive and it's going to make up make
I don't know I just imagine all the
feminists are going to lose their minds
at this episode it'll be funny or
they're gonna claim they're not really
offended whatever it'll be fun so become
a member at simcast.com you'll also be
supporting our journalists and all the
work they do smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
video be that notification because
people are telling us YouTube's not
notifying them anymore so you guys can
be that notification if you want to help
push back against the censorship what
about we're about a month at from the
midterm so it's a it's really important
joining us tonight is is a man who is
not in fact invisible but just late is
Bill admin hey thanks for having me you
were late I ran out of gas literally
totally spaced yeah man uh who are you
what do you do my name is Bill I'm the
co-founder of minesminds.com we're a
open source decentralized Social Network
all simple enough well Luke's here too I
guess unforgivable never do that again
Bill thank you I'm just messing up yes
my name is we are change.org today I'm
wearing a shirt with my co-host on it
and that of course is my dog Atlas which
reads no step on dog which you could
exclusively get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do I'm here thank you so much for having
me look I just had a son his name is
atlas
her name is atlas his and her so you
know they'll be friends awesome his son
is atlas oh your son's name's Atlas
that's pretty cool that's awesome cool
name are you call him Addie that hasn't
that hasn't emerged yet the nickname
hasn't come out it's not it's not so
much a nickname as this the way you say
the name Atlas yes you know just to
speak normally until you say his name
Atlas oh can you come here and bring
this baby it's becoming more and more of
a popular name as you know we have a
global Awakening to the True Crimes
happening all around the world are you
going to pile the burden of Earth on his
shoulders it's actually not earth that
he's dep that's a that's a myth it's uh
the celestial bodies it's the whole it's
a whole universe
on his shoulders all right well hey Ian
Crossland also co-founder of Mines I
don't talk about it enough probably on
the show good to have you here Bill hell
yeah let's re reconnoit her for sure
thank you guys all for joining us this
evening on this my last night I cannot
wait to talk about whatever's coming up
whenever dumb thing Bina said let's get
into it all right everybody here's the
story from the Daily Mail quote let me
start with two words made in America and
that was it and I just started busting
out laughing because uh you know look we
could talk about a lot of stuff we can
talk about Joe Biden destroying the
country and getting us involved in
potentially world war three but uh we
get we deserved we deserve to laugh and
I don't know if I okay so I don't have
it here do they got the video Let's Play
the video they start off with two words
made in America
made in America he says it twice and
then everybody cheers for it
that's it happy Friday everybody I hope
you're having a good time this is um
you know are we laughing as everything
just spirals down into Oblivion and we
just you know we're just smiling as it
all Burns around us this is fine uh not
also not all burning around us it's
always been you know trying to make the
best out of a chaotic uh Universe
um but yeah I'm definitely laughing as I
should probably be trying to figure out
a new sort of economy that we could
transition to I love how the story from
the Daily Mail is highlighting the fact
that he's had two words he's like let me
start with two words but then says three
but then it gets like really serious
with like letters you know from the rep
from representatives from Congresswoman
Nancy mace and pictures of you know Rand
Paul and all that stuff when it's like
dude I'll bet you the White House
transcript is going to read he said
three words instead of two and they're
gonna try to whitewash few words few
words there you go let me start with a
few words
Lydia pointed out he technically did
start with two made in so maybe he
wasn't one
yeah that's what Kareem jean-pierre's
gonna say someone's gonna be like the
president said to start with two words
but then said three
he started by saying two words and then
added a third okay that's two two how's
it going how's the economy for you guys
how's how's your how's the country are
you are you excited for the leadership
of this man oh yeah absolutely he's
definitely very competent and I'm so
happy he's in charge as we are on the
brink of Armageddon as he says himself
last night he was literally talking
about how we're we're closer to
Armageddon since the first time since
the Cuban Missile Crisis he's also
talking about how Putin is deadly
serious about using tactical nukes in
Ukraine and uh
Yeah well yeah look at that look at this
tweet this is a good one it's the first
it's it's uh one of these gotcha tweets
Joe Biden says you won't have to worry
about my tweets when I'm president and
then under it it says President Joe
Biden says the risk of nuclear
Armageddon is at the highest level since
the Cuban Missile Crisis my response was
yeah right I mean come on no Mean Tweets
yeah like there you go but I just love
that that juxtaposition you don't got to
worry about my tweets and then the news
the world is about to end
I wonder if he's setting us up to be a
hero like he's like hey I I have heard
in World War Three everybody we're like
yeah but you got us close to it too in
the first place hey but I did get you
away from it I mean it's like I saved
you from nuclear war like you almost
started it but I didn't save you from it
he did come out with the marijuana stuff
what was it yesterday yeah yeah but
apparently it's not actually exonerating
anybody the apparently the marijuana
thing is just going to like your past
convictions are you raced yeah I saw
that oh it's not letting people out no
it's not letting people out they can't
get out of jail
but for federal offenses
it seemed that it was a pardon I the
language pardon was in there for
thousands of I don't know if it's
current or past I think it's past I I so
I see a lot of these lefties being like
Joe Biden's a great president because he
just pardoned all these marijuana you
know convictions or whatever and I was
like oh that's cool like I'm I'm in
favor of that I think Trump should have
done the same thing and then and then my
response like how many people were
released and everyone said none it was
just exonerating like their records and
they're trying to reschedule it because
that's the value yeah right because if
they take it off a schedule one then
they'll stop treating it like heroin
yeah and stop throwing people in federal
prison for it isn't that crazy though
that basically the only reason pot
became legal is because everyone just
decided it was and ignored the law like
they were they were I I was talking
about this with Half Baked it's
literally a movie from the 2000s as if
it was it late 90s I don't know where a
bunch of dudes are just outright
committing crimes and it's relatable and
funny
it's just weird like even in it the you
know when Dave Chappelle is at the lab
and the doctor rips the huge chunk off
and hands it to him just like it's a
tragedy what they did to marijuana in
the 1900s that what was it Harry J Ann
Slinger and uh William Randolph Hearst
got together Hurst owned all these trees
and he wanted to take people off of the
hemp paper industry and make you know
well paper industry wanted to make trees
so he he got Harry J and Slinger and I
think he was the guy his Congress Point
man to start printing up all this
propaganda like Reefer Madness make
people afraid they said that black it
made black people like blood bloodlusty
and stuff like crazy
nonsensical propaganda that wasn't true
and uh they made enough people afraid of
it that they were able to make it
federally legal and then William Randall
first had the Monopoly on the paper
trade after that
it's stuck for a long time
I mean I think that's that's an
interesting story right he was uh he was
like a newspaper magnate or whatever
does that he pronounce that yeah you
look at the people who control the
narratives when they have the ability to
manipulate and control media and you see
what ends up happening because of it
they can just be like this thing goes
against my interest so have my
newspapers tell everybody to do as I say
and they do
freaking nuts but he did it with
congress's help which is what really
makes it scandalous yeah but the thing
about Congress
you know the Republicans are a great
example Republicans are more concerned
about the opinion of the New York Times
than the opinion of their own
constituents and that's that's exactly
the power of the media so with the
internet the reason why we're seeing big
Tech freak out the way it is and this
whole Elon Musk thing this becomes such
a big deal is we've we've I mean Oz I
guess you know many of us especially you
guys Minds we've taken away their
ability to just monopolize The Narrative
and they're losing their minds because
of it and they're losing power because
of it and they're you know it's like
it's like watching a dude sinking in
quicksand screaming and thrashing around
and you wanna you wanna feel bad you're
like I know that they're sinking and
they're like doomed but they're also
just really evil so you can only just
sit back and be like maybe they we
shouldn't have this apparatus anymore
you know what I mean yeah I'd still like
to encourage them to not thrash so much
because that's what's causing them to
sink maybe it's the thrashing that's
evil not the actual person it's yeah if
they just you know laid forward
and that you your legs come out and then
you can crawl away but they don't get it
they're just swinging violently
screaming and you know it's like when we
uh we had this raccoon problem and you
know we want to feel bad for this
raccoon but we're trying to kill our
chickens so when we walk up to the Trap
and we're like oh the poor little thing
is and we're like ah they're like get it
out of here and then wait to get rid of
it you know that's what it's like it's
it's the media is failing it's dying and
these people are losing their jobs and
all that and then I'm just like yeah but
they're like nasty people who just fling
crap at your face you know you walk up
to them you feel bad like maybe you know
these journalists you know I see they're
they're panicking maybe they need work
and they just fling feces right at you
and you're like okay dude okay go away
you don't deserve to have a job I guess
you would think Twitter would be
changing amid seeing the reaction to the
Elon takeover like but they still
they're thrashing they they continue to
ban even despite
this lawsuit that's happening and the
like so what is your current take on the
the situation like because Twitter wants
Elon Twitter wants the the court trial
to happen still yeah yeah because
because Elon was asking for more time
and they said making sure the trial
still happens until this finalizes like
prevents Mischief or something I guess
if they're poop tweets they're concerned
about I don't want any more poop emoji
from you know what man like ah just
bill was late to the show so normally
what we do is we get a thumbnail where
the guest is sitting across from me and
then I press record and then I
screenshot it but Bill wasn't here so I
was just like empty chair it is and I
just want to say like that's that right
there is the big difference between the
establishment and the traditional media
machine and what we represent we can
just screw around like that and be silly
about it and have fun and just it is
what it is and I was like if this was
like a major Network they'd be panicking
they'd be like pull archival we got to
get something we can't be we have to
wear our suits and ties yeah you can't
have fake bazunkas on National
Television no could you imagine a guest
going on Tucker Carlson with gigantic
fake boobies like Luke did yeah I mean
Fox would probably have you know
did you see that Danny project got got a
pair oh he did yeah good that from that
high school teacher thing or whatever
yeah he got he got like yeah he was
doing videos what's he doing I didn't I
I just saw a photo of it when they
arrived at his house I didn't see the
video yet what do you think of the Elon
buying Twitter I mean bring it on it's
better than status quo you know we saw
did you guys see his text with Dorsey
some of them yeah so it's like they both
are admit you know Dorsey what's
infuriating is that he knows open source
decentralization encryption Bitcoin he
knows that this is all where it needs to
go but he had decades to make that
happen with Twitter and couldn't do it
he even said in the text I don't have
power I have three percent of the
company I can't do anything but he was
telling Elon this is where you need to
take it he was saying there's there
needs to be no company actually because
the company becomes an attack Vector
right so
IT company lists decentralized Protocols
are what we need that's what's beautiful
about Bitcoin because Satoshi is totally
Anonymous no there's no one to go after
why is it why isn't why didn't Dorsey do
anything I I know he had that that one
operation what was that called this guy
blue sky right yeah it still exists it's
you know they're they're doing research
and stuff but I don't you know and then
when the transition happened and uh the
new CEO is coming in parag he Dorsey to
this blog post where he was like I feel
in my gut that this is really the right
decision for the company you know we're
gonna you know things are gonna get
better and then it's just like nothing
changes there's no you know in fact his
Prague statements about Free Speech are
the opposite like right so you know you
know be amazing like day one Elon gets
the company it converts into a
blockchain and then Twitter removes
itself from any moderation capabilities
it becomes a totally decentralized
networking tool so it's just like We
Can't Ban anybody anymore or he just
buys it and deletes it for the benefit
of the world screw it off could you
could he buy it and then like free like
free soft make all the code free well he
should and we should get pl3 but we need
the version history so that we can see
all the algorithm changes that they made
punishing people over the years that's
those are the skeletons that are in the
closet because every code change in git
there's a version history so you can see
oh they started punishing this type of
content on this date in you know the
election season and you know that that
data exists and like it needs to be
audited can they scrub version histories
not easily but they can
um
I don't I think that would be
unlikely I think that if he if he open
sources the code he said he was going to
open source it so hopefully he does so
so real quick real quick this is
important if Elon Musk does finalize his
buy to this company he's going to have
logs showing that Twitter was targeting
conservatives or people on the right yes
it's funny because uh they it's the
weirdest thing Gizmodo publishes a story
Facebook censoring conservative news
outlets I then go hey everybody wow
that's crazy you look Facebook censoring
then I get smeared as pushing conspiracy
theories for believing what Gizmodo
publishes it's going to be very
vindicating for everybody if Elon Musk
does do this so I certainly hope he does
but I have to wonder as well
I I think what's going to come out of
Twitter's closet is going to be more
than skeletons there's going to be some
real dark stuff we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna we'll probably see internal
Communications of them defending child
abusers and explaining why this you know
what I mean well this is gonna get
complicated because Elon is gonna have a
tough decision to make because he now is
responsible for this company and the
financial success of this this is why he
wants to take a private which makes
sense because he will have a fiduciary
duty to potentially not share a lot of
the skeletons which could get dicey so
Bill if I could ask you you have a lot
of history with social media obviously
with Minds if you were Elon Musk what
would you do right now
I mean I think he's doing what he can I
think he's he's like he's trying not to
buy it yeah yeah yeah but let's say the
the acquisition finally goes through you
have Twitter what would you do if you
were Elon with Twitter you immediately
open source all the code
you immediately make all the messages
and 10 encrypted so thousands of Twitter
employees can't read our messages it's
just like so absurd didn't Facebook edit
end encryption no WhatsApp says they did
or the Saudi government can't read
protesters private DMS and messages of
Human Rights activists through Twitter I
got a question do you think that Twitter
receives money from governments to allow
them backdoors
I think that it is I I don't know
Verizon does at T does right so so I
think there's a strong possibility
the one of the reasons Elon may have
backed out
is he may have gone to Twitter and says
I want to buy the company and they went
here are the lucrative contracts keeping
the company afloat that you can never
reveal because governments are paying
for back doors and you can't reveal
those and then Elon went crap it might
not just be contracts it might be just
threats and and do rest of the
government saying we're going to shut
you down or we're going to make sure you
can't do business if you don't do what
you want well that's 100 and then and
then like 15 years ago we were reporting
on specific stories of the NSA of the
federal government having their own
office spaces inside of the headquarters
of Verizon a t T-Mobile the major cell
phone providers in this country had
entire floors dedicated to the federal
government that was spying and watching
on everyone what what's Twitter what's
Twitter involved in it's like it's like
that movie The Santa Claus with Tim
Allen how like being Santa is actually a
curse you guys know what I'm talking
about right like Santa's on his roof and
then Tim Allen kills the guy and then
steals his clothes and for some reason
puts them on and then becomes Santa and
loses family and then it it's like a
mind virus that makes him happy about it
right now I'm and I am some someone
being cute but no what I mean is Elon
Musk or anybody it feels like he goes to
Twitter and they're like no no no no
don't buy this company don't buy this
company and then finally they're like
okay buy the company and now they're
looking at this like we are going to get
paid to leave and not have to be
involved in this behind the scenes
National Security BS I I would bet I if
if here's a way I'll play it if I went
to a casino and I saw Blackjack roulette
and do you think the net that the US
government has National Security letter
sent to Twitter demanding back doors I
would put all my money on that I'm not
playing another game because that's a
Sure Shot Elon Musk comes in asks them
like okay show me corporate documents
and he's got an NDA and not only that
but a national security letter with a
gag order from the government and he
went
crap and they're like you can't say
anything about it you have to buy it and
if and when you do buy it you won't be
able to do anything you want to do
because they will force you to give them
the back doors and we already saw the
White House going to Facebook and saying
ban these people there is a zero percent
chance they they did not do that with
Twitter but and Elon probably saw that
yeah it's not just a back door to the
information I think it's even more than
that I think it's deciding who gets
censored deciding which voices get
downranked in the algorithm I think the
federal government is way more involved
not just with of course the intelligence
agencies helping give a lot of these big
Tech social media companies their start
but but what do you think of this
running your own social media Network
what's the possibility of what me and
Tim are talking about
yeah very likely I mean well we saw the
Alex Berenson all this these Discovery
documents came out recently between
Twitter and the White House where Alex
Berenson got banned from Twitter and
sued them exactly it's the slack
conversation of the Twitter employees
saying oh you know I forget the guy's
name at the White House said why is Alex
Berenson still on the platform so to
amend my earlier statement when I said
that's a zero percent chance no actually
the evidence already been released by
Alex Berenson yeah yeah and then the the
the the the the thing I was pointing to
is when they were talking about
Instagram I think when the White House
was like Hey this one's not ours can you
do something about it it was the Anthony
fauci parody
so we know the government they're doing
the wink wink nudge nudge yeah and I
think worse than that obviously but I'm
I'm wondering if say this Saudis they go
to Twitter and say how much will it cost
to get access to your to your back end
to your to get back doors Twitter needs
money
I think it's possible for Elon to switch
past but he's gonna have to start
playing Hardball with major countries
and risking Twitter getting banned in
those countries if he doesn't play ball
you know it's it's a marketing dream for
a com you know SpaceX and Tesla to have
Twitter as a you know marketing engine
for those companies so you know it makes
a lot of sense for Elon it's a question
of in order to do this Elon has to get
Banks to back it money has to come from
somewhere and no one is willing to pay
full the full price to take the platform
and then just convert it into a
blockchain open source decentralized
network if that were to happen You Can't
Ban anybody ever again you know they can
co-exist though like you can have a
centralized infrastructure and a
decentralized infrastructure running
parallel we actually just integrated
with a new network called Noster which
stands for notes and other stuff
transmitted by relay it is a there's
relays all over the world everybody has
a crypto key pair that we don't have
access to his Minds that's your identity
you can bring your followers and your
content and log into other apps you can
leave you can leave us it's not a
blockchain but it's a distributed system
so you know there's and there's other
projects out there that are like this
you've got the fediverse you've got
activity pup you've got uh farcaster is
the new one you've got planetary you've
got secure scuttlebutt there's all these
protocols that are like in the mix and
Twitter can integrate and Facebook and
all Rumble other networks I'm trying
we're going to talk with them about
integrating like we can all join these
open products yeah we can get all of the
alternative Tech sites to join as well
so we're all participating but that
doesn't mean you have to abandon the
existing infrastructure as well they can
run in parallel and Elon did express
interest in working with Rumble uh so I
think that also is is giving a lot of
people optimism but but as we're talking
about here Twitter is a major Powerhouse
Twitter is is a vector of influence that
a lot of powerful governments need and
want in their fingertips and it would be
foolish to think that their fingertips
and fingers and hands aren't already in
this larger influence uh that Twitter
and big Tech social media has just uh in
2019 there was an ex-twitter employee
that was found guilty for spying for the
Saudi government specifically going
through private messages going after
dissidents of the Saudi Empire and
sharing that information directly with
Muhammad bin Salman so so again that's
just one example Twitter's Revenue model
is Twitter's addicted to surveillance
advertising just like Facebook and so
Elon needs to rip that out you know Elon
knows how to make money he knows how to
make people people pay like you know 50
to 100K for a car like he has some of
the most profitable you know money
making machines in the world
he can figure out how to make Twitter
way more profitable without doing all
the nonsense I it is possible yeah you
do something like super Minds yeah where
like you could send somebody an offer
and then they can accept the offer to
respond so back to back to the question
because we cut you off really quickly
this one you were back to this yeah
let's talk more about these you were
Elon Ian Ian feel free to jump in on
this if you're Elon as well you have
Twitter what do you do that's my
question you said he open source
everything yeah do you so would that
reinstate everybody obviously when you
say open source you mean agpl3 like a
free like there's another license
there's multiple licenses that that
could work I hope that he actually does
it because I remember when all those
news came out about oh Tesla's open
sourcing their batteries remember yeah
yeah that was not real that was that he
he just decided not to be a patent troll
he decided to sort of open the patent so
he wasn't going to go around suing other
competitors in the general space but
like the code of you know the software
running on Tesla is the battery
blueprints none of that is is open
source yeah so the difference between a
lot of the cars is just the software
yeah that you're paying for that's not
open source yeah the same software that
is running the AI on on the new
um you know Tesla Bots is the same is
what's running in the car it's the same
system I got an idea
so we're talking to this uh this uh
fabricator metal fabricator guy about
building a one-of-a-kind unique electric
car we should do it with mines it should
be powered by mines so like your your
digital console is like a mines console
oh yeah because you need an operating
system right and an app within the so
let's do it yeah so uh we can do it
really we were talking we can make like
a really cheap electric car and I was
like as a gag we have like a 2006 Cobalt
with 230 000 miles on it and I was like
yeah let's do that and not fix anything
and be like boom one of a kind uh or we
could actually make a really cool car
like actually works and everything we
should have it like integrate with mines
let's do it I I saw some there's some
amazing like refurbishing companies that
can take like any car and just make an
electric car like there's this one uh
page on uh I forget it's it's they
take Volkswagen specifically and they'll
make it any Volkswagen electric from any
period of time I'm gonna make the
Flintstone car and beat all of you guys
including Tesla when the EMP goes off
and nuclear Armageddon happens but will
you run now no no like the funny thing
with the Flintstones car is like pedals
exist we've discovered that quite a bit
uh quite a long time ago yeah but it
doesn't look as funny in the cartoons
when you're pedaling with yourself you
ever see those cars where there's
there's two sets of pedals in the front
in the back and everyone in the car is
pedaling and it's going there you go man
I was just going to say that I
did ask uh we we sent a message to Elon
asking this question I don't know if if
he'll answer it but
there needs to be a Tesla that is not
subject to just getting shut down from
Tesla HQ like you're talking about like
like I could see him getting behind that
like a Tesla that's Sovereign and like
the software's running locally so that
it's just not like sketchy dystopian
possibility but do you know that um I'm
not sure Luke if you know this some of
them have cameras pointing at you the
driver and if you aren't paying
attention or something it alerts you and
it records that it uses it against you
that is nightmares it has that history
too yeah yeah because I because uh I saw
in the console of the model S there's a
camera and I was like is that I Googled
it I'm like is that's cool like because
you know Uber drivers for instance they
turn cameras on to film their passengers
and I'm like that could be helpful if
there's a car accident if you're side
swept or something you have no access to
that camera it is for them to spy on you
as you drive creepy so there's no
obviously you can't log into your Tesla
account and check out yeah like what
data is Maybe I'm Wrong Maybe I'm Wrong
Maybe I'm wrong I don't know I doubt
that they give you access to all the the
footage of but you think no no no no so
the side cameras you can't like oh yeah
so I can pull up my phone right now and
look at my car in the garage the model
three yeah yeah that's really cool like
but there's an internal camera and I'm
like what is that all about the CIA has
access to all of it live as it's going
on uh most likely uh without it without
a doubt the NSA yeah there's no way that
they don't so you know I I you know I
would automatically tape up that camera
as fast as I can uh but I heard some car
manufacturers take away your ability to
do self-driving if you cover up that
camera because the cameras are focused
on your eyes to make sure that your eyes
are focused on the road and if your eyes
and hands aren't focused on on the road
and the wheel they stop automatic
driving and make you drive instead of
having the car drive you you guys know
that basically like all new cars are
self-driving so Tesla has full
self-driving capability only after your
car has driven on the highway on
autopilot for 100 miles you have a high
safety score and they approve you so my
model 3 apparently just got recently
like congratulations it's now entitled
to full self-driving and that's where
the car will actually stop at the stop
sign check and then slowly turn right in
the steering wheel spinning by itself
but most of them when people think of
like oh the Teslas can drive themselves
and then you get in the Tesla for the
first time and you're like autopilot and
you're like wow all it does is just the
steering wheel moves a little bit left
and right on the highway that's it it'll
speed up slow down
and then I so when I first saw that when
I got the model three I was like whoa
this is crazy I'm like I'm on the
highway and like it's moving itself then
I got out then I got a Honda
it's got the same thing huh modern Honda
is the exact same thing no difference
it's it's Auto steer and cruise control
so I'm on the highway and I'm like oh
that's what they call it auto steer it's
called something like Lane correction or
something like that I don't know but
it's it's it so the Honda can't activate
a full self drive like the Tesla can but
Teslas don't come with that anyway you
have to earn a special pilot you know a
beta or something could Honda run a
self-driving upgrade probably remotely I
have to imagine if they can drive
themselves on the highway they can drive
themselves in the streets so I don't
know I think the Teslas don't use sonar
anymore or radar or something like that
and it switched to just camera and I
noticed this because I think when they
switched it it got way worse
it like doesn't understand what's going
on anymore and I I wonder why maybe
statistically the radar or stone or
whatever it was was worse and now like
cameras are better but then if you get
like Schmutz on the on the camera or
something then it just turns off on you
I was driving in the rain and I have it
on on self-drive autopilot on the
highway and it's I'm going 70 miles an
hour and it's making a turn and then we
get close to a semi and it goes boom
boom it just turns off and I'm like what
the like that's scary you keep your
hands on the wheel the whole time but
when so you're going with it when it
stops just like whoa
it sounds tragedy waiting to happen man
that people they encourage you to take
your hands off the wheel
how is that going to make you more
attention
so they want you to be sitting there
like a zombie but still somehow be more
like you're gonna become less attentive
to what's going on if you're not
actually supposed to be attending to it
how can that be good you you for the
self-driving you have to have weight on
the steering wheel your hands have to be
on it if you take them off it'll go
all you should be doing is watching the
road and paying attention to the road
when you're driving in which case
there's no difference between you moving
the steering wheel a few millimeters and
it moving a few millimeters itself it is
convenient when you're changing the
radio and you're not scared of dying
because it's helping you but you know
look I'm driving in the rain I turned on
self-drive and I'm sitting there the
whole time like okay yeah but what about
what about for people who like pass out
driving that could it could it'll save
lives yeah but here's the here's the
problem it won't actually to a certain
degree if autopilot is on and then you
have a mental a medical episode you'll
probably be safer than if you didn't
have autopilot but this thing won't
break it's like it breaks for the
stupidest things I'm I'm the light is
green and it goes breaking for green
light and I'm like why and you gotta
press the accelerator there was a
there's a stoplight a head sign it's a
picture of a stop light and the Tesla
stops for it and so you have to press
the accelerator otherwise here's the
craziest thing it's raining I'm driving
straight and someone's pulling onto the
highway and they're going slow waiting
for him to pass and all of a sudden the
Tesla slammed the brakes on to Zero from
70. and we just like lunge forward like
this has happened three times just this
past weekend and so it got to the point
where we're like maybe we should not use
this anymore yeah maybe wait 15 or 20
years till after they stopped testing
right next to where the tree it went to
like seven wow it went from 70 just like
slammed the brakes on in the rain and
then the truck trying to come in slams
his brakes on like what are you doing
and I'm just like that is not sane the
fantasy is you take your driver's seat
and you spin it around and you and your
passenger spins theirs around and
there's four of you all hanging out in
the back of the car while it's driving
you that's the fantasy that they're
aiming for but I mean good God there's
no tracks it's not a train wind can push
the car a kid can knock a basketball out
into the road on accident but there is
one thing to add to this when all cars
communicate with each other then you
have a lot less to worry about but it's
going to have to be more than all cars
it'll be like satellites and houses and
telephones and they'll all be telling
everyone where everyone is and all the
machines will know and they'll be
anticipating but Ian it'll be okay it'll
be in the metaverse you'll be one safer
you'll be in the machine you will be the
machine you have always been driving a
driving a car is very dangerous and
there are a lot of people that die every
single day just from driving a car a lot
of people don't realize how actually
dangerous statistically it is so I think
this self-driving will be sold as hey
we're going to make everyone safe No
One's Gonna Die from car accidents
anymore if all the cars are self-driving
therefore none of the cars are going to
be crashing into each other I think
that's the latest Ploy that's how
they're going to get rid of truckers
that's how they're going to get rid of
taxi drivers that's how they're going to
get of any any driver it'll be a legal
Drive they'll be like cars they've
talked about this cars in the future
will not have the ability to be driven
or your insurance will be so drastically
more expensive not only that but in
Europe they're already limiting cars
that can't go above a certain uh miles
per hour like uh kilometers per hour or
whatever they have over there in Europe
but but they're limiting you know roads
they measure things in in stone exactly
like and turtle shells totally
nonsensical ways
but but there's already government
shutdown
um switches that they have in European
cars that are going to be developed very
soon where the government will have the
access to particular vehicles and to be
able to turn them off anytime that they
want you guys were saying if there's a
health emergency for a driver their
hands come off the wheel that this but
doesn't you say when they shut off
self-driving shuts off and then you
crash no no okay no way so it doesn't
even help that right oh no but like if
if you are for about 30 seconds I think
it will it'll start like if you pass out
it'll wake you up
but if you're having a seizure if you're
having a seizure or something it's not
going to help so there so uh over Hills
is hilarious they cannot drive over
Hills because the cameras can't see
anything so I just immediately once you
go up the hill once you get to the top
if you're driving
and there's an error for some reason
I've had auto drive shut off as error
disengaging you'll just go straight off
the road It's Gonna Keep the they will
keep getting better because what all of
your data is just training data right so
it's over time and now there's Teslas
everywhere it was crazy I'm driving
around every third car sees like a Tesla
and I'm just like wow they're everywhere
man are your Tesla's going to be
tweeting at you
tweeting at you I'm low on gas you'll
get a tweet from gas Tim pools Tesla
yeah or I'm low on charge I only have 32
charge at Tim cast they already do that
they don't tweet at me and my thing
buzzing it's like Luke was driving my
Tesla he left the door open and then it
was like your door is open and I am like
I don't care it's in the garage and then
like I wake up with like 12
notifications like your door is open he
used to watch Knight Rider for sure dude
he's trying to build kit it's gonna be
like a very funny joke at Tim cast and
you're like oh thanks Tesla he's not
gonna say yeah
with stable diffusion or Dolly oh Dolly
so dolly is the closed Source version
stable diffusion is where it's at but
it's yeah it's is that where you can
like Auto generate yeah pictures we did
that didn't yeah we did that on the show
I think we did a bunch of AI generations
of like Trump and Pelosi and it was like
nightmarishly hilarious they're scary a
lot of Damages are like what's it called
stable diffusion stable diffusion you
can it's not like a company it's it's a
project so you can't just uh stability
if you go to replicate.com you can yeah
stability they created it um do they
have can I can I use it here wow
replicate.com replicate is a good place
to use stable to food replicate.com you
have to you have to you have to pay oh I
see I see I see oh that's a that's a
profit Market weight Oh yeah talk about
you don't have to hire employees to do a
bunch of your stuff but stable diffusion
is dominating Dali now so open AI which
Elon actually was a part of I'm not sure
if he's really how involved he is now
but you know most of they're not most of
their code's not even open some of their
stuff is so they do some open source but
they were trying to make the argument
that
stable diffusion would be bad for
artists because it's going to put them
out of business because people can just
if they need a graphic generated they
can just go have you seen the video
generators no okay so wow I typed in
stable diffusion demo bill ottman this
is what we got here we go nice abortion
Wells all right kind of looks like you
I've got something on my bones I don't
understand who this is and why do you
think it's you gotta be worse than one
Ottoman Empire probably oh it's ottoman
yeah oh I see generate image lucrid
Caskey this is this really is good the
dolly mini was not that good we'll get
we'll get Joe Biden in there in a second
but let's even get Luke gradkowski
what is this
what is this
what is what are you doing Luke are
those space swords
wow type in Temple all right it's just
gonna show a swimming pool
you can't you just you just can't get it
maybe
I think I have to put in like Tim cash
or something
let's see or you have to put it in
quotes the word would that work quotes
maybe dream Studio beta
30 years
Whoa man that looks more like Chris in
the upper right that was so creepy that
was wild it was it was like some of it
was kind of close it wasn't a pool
facial hair whoa it was not a pool
clearly you and the bald one how do you
know about that
you have more photos in the you know the
machine learning library oh this is
really accurate the LA the bottom left
one dude this is okay I'm bothered by
this you know why it's not funny well
you have to do a sentence like dude
eating a cat yeah
dude
and they're saying they're making it's a
very it's a very important news show we
run here
Joe Biden eating a cat
you'll be in the metaverse and you'll be
like you'll think something and it will
appear in front of you that's crazy dude
[Laughter]
right
here
we go
uh Donald Trump hug no no wait wait wait
High fiving Joe Biden there we go it's
all about Unity It's All About Love yeah
we got to bring it together hi Donald
Trump high-fiving Joe Biden it looks
like the sentences take a little longer
to render yeah there's more in it this
is great let's do uh let's do Nancy
Pelosi stealing
covet masks
here we go it's loading Nancy Pelosi
robbing citizens oh that's amazing dude
wow look at Joe Biden and Donald Trump
shaking hands that's an image I've
wanted to see for a long time and we've
made it a reality through the the
through artificial bottom right be funny
if you ran uh news like for timcast
articles that run the headline through
this to generate the thumbnail for the
news story that's actually a good idea
do we have the rights to that you do
yeah Hunter Biden going to jail
let's just let's just fulfill our
wildest dreams with uh with this uh
dream Studio it Luke's taking a picture
of it I'm setting my team I'm like this
is how we're gonna do thumbnails
he went to the jail to see Joe who was
in the jail but I don't think he is that
smart
dude I'm loving the bottom left
hey it looks like the guy from uh Better
Call Saul the bad guy do you want
Vladimir Putin Joe Biden World Peace
I wonder how esoteric this thing gets
Putin's misspelled
putting Vladimir Putin signing peace
treaty with Biden it's too busy no no no
no no no don't you do this one I cannot
do it
impossible not gonna happen
what if what if we do like Donald Trump
in Drag
yes all night
here we go Vladimir Putin's oh I put
singing peace treaty that works too
let's see what happens yeah I'm into it
singing peace treaty with Biden
Fridays are fun aren't they yeah come on
give me what's this it's still going oh
there we go is he signing it with
himself that is weird it's Putin signing
a deal with himself all of them are what
is this
these two are just Putin signing deals
with food which just proves this inner
conflict this is Putin's inner conflict
Madness and change signing to sing yeah
singing
with Joe Biden oh man I think I think
maybe because we did the show people
have started using it oh cool type in
World War Three oh that's a good it'll
show like Joe Biden or or woke world
three
yeah this this will eventually be able
to generate a movie probably and it'll
just yeah there's an app the one you
were saying it it there's a commercial
for I forgot what it's called but I saw
it on Twitter and it's it's you can type
in a video and it will make a video for
you and it like it's a loading bar it
takes some time to generate but someone
wrote b-roll footage of moving through a
forest towards a lake and then it's like
you see the trees and it was dude people
be like show me a 35-year life of me
having three boys and a wife and a
beautiful house and they will live 35
years in their own ad generated
environment you're in it now oh that
makes sense because it's gonna be it's
gonna be worse than that you guys you
guys but you don't realize I'm having
fun yeah but there's two putins look at
this this here you go look at this
there's two buttons that's so
interesting
this right here this one this one's
pretty good actually the AI knows that
they have body doubles now what you
don't realize is Ian you're wrong about
that it's going to be a guy being like I
want two big titty women and I want them
in front of me and it's gonna you know
you know it's gonna get worse the porn
industry is gonna take it over all right
come on guys world league of Threes
world war three world war three show me
world war three I want to [ __ ]
here we go oh it's taking a long time on
this one
uh how does it what is it doing Google
or something I don't actually know the
full library of what it's pulling from
this is awesome yeah yeah bookmark this
this is legit and there's all different
things dot Co yeah hugging face is a
cool AI word to war
with two r's yeah this is like it's just
Sports language when you put it in yeah
wow did you hear like that map did you
hear that the AI created its own
language yeah Facebook Ai No no no no
there was uh uh it was Dolly I think I'm
not sure but one of these Auto
generators
started people would you would type in
like a bowl of vegetables and there
would be like a weird word that would be
like vlogabo and then when you type that
in it would give you the same kind of
vegetable every time something about the
AI created a word that represented an
image it was crazy yeah because you can
do this in Reverse as well so you can
feed an image and it'll spit text oh
yeah yeah what's this website called
hugging face is a it's an AI Community
it's talkingface.com I'm I'm down to
just keep generating images all night
because this is hilarious I'm trying to
oh everybody's hitting it up now and I
can't get it to work anymore you know I
had one guys let's get some let's let's
see let's get one with Lydia for her
last episode all right and she comes
back we got I typed in Ian Crossland we
didn't do him yet anything good well
it's common it's common good okay
what if it shows like Ian on a throne of
skulls give me Ian Crossland mushrooms
after this
that search result oh it's common here
we go
I think I think it'll get it I think
it'll get it you will who is this there
I am what is this is
yeah
what is this he says enio Greece there's
a lot of Ian's out there what are you
who's this guy and is he selling me a
product people used to be like you're
like Bill Nye he's like a comedian but
he likes science and I was like he's the
second American Civil War
um hey final question or one other
question I had about the Elon
acquisition of Twitter you said open
source everything was that hyperbole are
there like
um security algorithms that you don't
open source when open sourcing an entire
library of uh social networks code oh I
mean yeah don't you don't open source
the data but the code there's not reason
to not open it like even even um
security stuff yeah no open source
encryption is better encryption it's
it's it's
generally agreed upon that it's the most
audited it's the most battle tested just
because you open source that doesn't
mean that people can hack it and when
you say don't open source the data
what's the data you're everybody's yeah
check it out you can't even it's a
second American Civil War but it just
gives you the first um
all right let's uh Lydia from timcast
here we go
there you go Lydia we're making a robot
in the only the only thing not to open
source that they would not want to would
be like how Bots you know instructions
for Bots to get around the bot detection
is that what is this oh it looks nothing
like there she is who is Tom Tom dinner
laboda
fascinating thanks robot
I'll take it who is this that's so weird
look at that upper left is that like a
Boudoir image or something yeah that's
what it looks like holy cow it's like
you and your spare time hashtag never
Lids seriously
[Laughter]
there you go
come on there we go oh cool you can just
Spam click it
well I did I did try the Luke radkowski
what did we get we got something weird
didn't we yeah something some weird
rounds
somewhat similarly somewhat looks like
me that's why I think Luke we are
changed I wonder if I do it all as one
word or like an at symbol I used to want
to be famous because I wanted to give
like an Oscar speech but now I won't be
famous because I want these AIS to be
active
it's gonna be like conspiracy theorist
what is this oh looking good wee wee we
know we've uh then is I guess not a word
we were changed
[Laughter]
I wonder what makes it think of this
it's like lots of white like that looks
like the Arabic alphabet a little bit on
the upper right one I mean that's just
from an American you know Schwab eating
bugs good one all right after this one I
did Nancy Pelosi eating too many nachos
oh I know we should do Sheamus Sheamus
dropping potatoes yeah yeah Sheamus
coglin potato
will actually be a potato I wonder what
happened if I typed in Freedom Tunes
though
all right here we go guys Nancy Pelosi
eating too many nachos
yeah she has some very huge nachos Cloud
Schwab eating bugs I really want to see
that one
Klaus Schwab eating bugs
let's get it come on because everybody
wants to use it all right it's going oh
there's a cue I see
is this just huggingface.io or doc dot
Co yeah okay now you're making more
people use it no I can't even it
wouldn't vote for me it says no no
results found oh really hugging face
that's yeah that's kind of scary thought
that's uh disturbing it's from Alien
yeah facehuggers I don't like that oh
weird no it doesn't look like maybe
with younger who how about I got one
Bill Gates
eating Cricket huh or man boobs man
boobs
you can fulfill it's just a normal
picture you should do like Bill Gates
workout Bill Gates in Gulag Bill Gates
hot body
okay with a six-pack actually I'm
wondering if I could do that it'd be
interesting oh yeah what if we did like
um Bill Gates head on giraffe
oh that's cool all right Bill Gates
eating crickets
look at this one
he's so happy in the wow that's so weird
he looks pretty healthy I don't see
those yeah he's a lot skinnier than he
is in real life yeah and no man gigantic
bugs Bill Gates
head on a cricket oh cricket
oh good giraffe giraffes are like cooler
yeah be more noticeable
the application is too busy remember
when we talked about news and stuff no
no no no this is way more fun this is
the future right now we're we're giving
you the early scoop on what's coming
yeah this probably won't work very well
on on iTunes people are going to listen
to this being like I have no idea what
they're talking about but what do you
think about the because so open AI is
making the argument that it need they
should keep it closed because it's going
to put artists out of business the
opposite and put it your asset on Bill
Gates body
I think the the ability for artists to
capitalize and make money off of their
art is a relatively new thing like only
until TV and you kind of when you could
control your own
um
dispersion of the art like before you
had patrons it was all patronage based
because it's it's easy to do anyone can
do it I'm kind of shocked that people
there's an industry for it you know we
you know Ian you're making the point
about how you're going to say show me my
life 35 years with two kids it's it's
one thing we didn't actually expect when
we were talking about the metaverse you
know in the past couple of years we've
been talking about linking your brain
into neuralink and doing the metaverse
that you're going to be in this pre-pro
like you're going to be in Lord of the
Rings you're going to be in Skyrim
little did we realize what it's actually
going to be like is it's a blank slate
you're going to plug in your brain and
it's going to be a white dead space and
you're gonna go
mythical universe
orc monsters
and I'm a knight fighting my way to save
the princess and then just creates that
Universe in front of you Auto generates
it and then you live it it's like the
metaverse is something you're going to
create in real time it's like the
Holodeck only
you're gonna plug your brain into it but
do you think it'll completely take over
your visual
field and or it will be like happening
in the background and simultaneously
you'll have your current visual field
but there will also be iparallel one
oh that's creepy because like you know
it's like you wouldn't want to have
knurling just wipe out your whole field
of vision so it's like how can your can
your brain comprehend an expanded field
of vision is the question because you'd
want you'd want to be able to feel you'd
want to be able to see but at the same
time you'd probably want to be able to
still like you don't want to black out
yeah but I don't know man I think the
the the Sci-Fi view of things is that
it will take over your mind like you see
the Black Mirror where the guy goes in
the video game and bangs his buddy you
know there's one yes he yeah so you've
seen it he goes into a fighting game and
then he plays as some like Asian dude
but then his friend places some chick
and then they end up banging because for
whatever reason the game programmed that
in I guess I don't know I'm playing this
game called XCOM uh UFO defense it's
like you play as this Corporation that's
defending Earth against this Alien
Invasion and there's this enemy group of
humans that are plugged into the neural
net they're called exalt and they can
like see each other's visions and stuff
but if you can hack their Network they
go blind and they can't hear you they'll
run right past you they don't which so
there's a that's a terrifying
vulnerability to a neural net is that
people can shut off your perceptions
like Ghost in the Shell dude in uh
Standalone complex that anime is amazing
they uh this hacker hacks your brain so
you can't see him
super cool that show's great I think
it's going to be both I think you're
going to be you're gonna be able to see
multiple things in parallel whether or
not you can focus on multiple things is
going to be a learning process for the
human brain but then you're also going
to have the ability to shut it off and
go into like a video game like I'm like
looking at a monitor like a 360 degree
monitor I I got one more ask uh and I'm
and I promise I'm done uh I would really
love to see if the AI could figure this
one out Jeffrey Epstein's Client List
if if if we could solve this crime right
now with this artificial intelligence
I'd be very happy what if we do it and
it's just like Bill Clinton Bill Gates
you know yeah yeah Kevin Spacey uh Chris
Tucker uh who else you know look at
Jean-Luc brene Putin's sitting on the
throne of skulls oh had no problem doing
that yeah all right let's do uh
Jeffrey epson's Client List
here we go can this thing see into the
future can we solve can we be our modern
day Scooby-Doo
and solve this real life the mystery
gang how we put into an AI generator and
it made a list for us that proves it
all right well the information's out
there it's just being denied to everyone
so maybe the AI has the access to the
doj's uh yeah the files and they can
release the information
upper right who's that is that zoom in
hold on can you zoom in okay here we go
okay that looks like Bill Clinton right
there here's here's okuni oh met we got
him
here's one
that's all the possibilities how he
really looks right now after all the
plastic surgery it's like when you read
in a dream that's what the letters look
like at least for me they do they look
like swirling shapes like that that's so
weird you all know who you are are we is
our brain just a neural net
just trying to piece together
information as unchaotically as possible
I don't know man
Jack besoba talked about this with the
AI
there's a there's a website where it's
like this person is not real have you
ever seen that you load it and auto
generates a fake face and he said if you
keep doing it the demons start peeking
out oh yeah and we were like what does
that mean he's like don't do it don't do
it so we start doing it loading this
thing and it's just showing random faces
and they're like kind of off but
eventually if you do too many times you
start getting weird like black hole eyes
like peeking around the corners and just
really creepy stuff yeah dude super
creepy Shaggy Rogers
Shaggy Rogers there you go that
beautiful man Peter Pan his eyes are so
blue yeah is that what Shaggy looks like
in real life is that is that what Shaggy
should only be so lucky look at that hat
backstreet boy it's like a Luigi hat
Velma
Dinkley
wait wait Dinkley that's her last name
right yes but not gay
I wonder if it can handle negatives it
won't be able to find it okay
yeah I don't know if you think the a can
handle like a weird phrase like that
it's like this will be dressed like
Daphne watch dressed like Daphne
that's the biggest news of the week I
hope everybody realizes that not only is
Velma gay but they made Velma and Shaggy
black oh I re-watched a bunch of old
Scooby-Doo last night at least a little
bit for sure Scooby and Shaggy are high
as hell they constantly have the
munchies that the whole show is about
them eating like sandwiches eating dog
constantly hungry yeah so uh that's nice
look at this
that's kind of scary that's horrifying
yeah what is that she looks like she's
12 years old she's so weird I don't like
that let's let's try and do like what do
you think we can we can we can have it
generate that would be like serious
legitimate and interesting Alex Jones on
a unicorn okay well that's kind of but
I'll do it anyway
oh Atlantis the lost city of Atlantis
what let's do that I got that one can
you ask it questions what did Atlantis
look like or we're treating it like
historical the lost city yeah it's
literally just like a machine smashing
things together and we're like give us
how about this you guys uh chatter Super
Chat like what's the most profound
interesting thing we could generate that
make us go like oh you know I don't know
because we're doing silly stupid
nonsense and I wonder if someone did say
Alex Jones on a unicorn I do want to see
Alex across my mind I'm just saying
so this is what happens when when Bill
comes in and he's like there's an AI
generator it works and we're like all
right the whole show is now this Bill
Gates pregnant demons people getting
pregnant fauci Wuhan lab people are
saying here we go okay Anthony fauci I
think that's cool in Wuhan
virology lab
[Laughter]
there we go Atlantis is cool someone
wrote poop balls no nightmare fuel alien
life I think some of these generators uh
don't allow NSFW as well not safe for
work oh yeah when I go to
huggingface.com is there another button
I gotta push to go to that I don't even
know Google search it I will search
stable diffusion I actually haven't used
this one before Anthony fauci in Wuhan
virology lab whatever just shows us got
an actual photo here it is wow that's
amazing leaked these people do not look
at this no but here's the crazy thing is
it actually just shows like Chinese
people working in a lab with Anthony
fauci look at
so they're like these these are just
actual pictures we got for you right
yeah
these are real actually look at her face
yeah well that's what happens when
you're exposed to the viruses in these
Labs yeah yeah that makes sense all
right what's what's what other what I
want someone said Ian shaft cam I don't
know
Alex Jones on a unicorn yeah
riding a unicorn on a unicorn right on
here we go people are demanding it I'm
seeing it in the chat
dude their stock is rising so is there a
company behind this yeah I think so is
that uh stability well stable diffusion
is a model hugging face basically
embedded this model into their site so
hugging face didn't make stable
diffusion I think stability AI did oh
awesome but it's open so anyone can
embed it in their site like you could
embed we're thinking of having this
auto-generate avatars by default on
mines for people who don't have avatars
yeah or based on your current uh
trending stuff that you've been able to
change it daily or something yeah oh no
no
God before humans huh God before
Humanity it's gonna create like an
archetypal or like a stereotypical you
know religious image you know what about
if you type in Satan was the good guy
I'm gonna do that on my personal
computer yeah so you come up with Satan
was the good guy yeah I wonder if they
can fathom that
it's an AI it's like it's it I don't
know you can probably put it I could
probably put like orange
car jet yeah look it's what is this what
is this thing this
this thing it says there's three what
Obito Obito the Todd ten fiema
amla tovane I'm not gonna finish rematch
all right what else is someone the edge
of the universe biblically accurate
accurate Angel yeah
it's going to be a picture of like a
spaceship something like that maybe
someone asked for Alex Jones gorilla
Alex Jones as a gorilla yeah
we can do that I wonder if it does a
different render every time with the
same sentence it does different or the
best president of the United States
someone just said that as well oh yeah
people are saying you can download the
stable division Ai and just do it on
your own computer
there you go so powerful biblically
accurate Angel and it's like not
biblically accurate not at all
Alex Jones as a gorilla
Lydia those aren't like the Angels
you've seen no it's not like the Angels
Live scene those ones are scary there's
a reason they say do not be afraid when
they first introduce themselves to
humans
Alex Jones where they look like they're
giant serpent monster or something
they're no they have like eight Wings
they have like ten faces they have like
a million eyes it's really horrifying
sounding
a fluffy little fat angels
they're like smoke this Don't Panic it's
Alex Jones it's just a gorilla yeah but
it sucks and it only means
all right let's see ask the AI for the
meaning of life Anderson Cooper eating
sponge cake well I don't know about that
one no thanks Ian on the couch after the
apocalypse oh
it doesn't know me Donald Trump fighting
necro Morse from dead space this is the
best song
what if it like nails it perfectly
here we go
Donald Trump fighting Necromorphs from
Dead Space
I just want to see dead space that
sounds cool
it's a game they're just releasing a new
Dead Space actually yeah that is that
creepy right it's like you go on like an
abandoned ship I think so yeah derelict
let's do one of Elon afterwards oh yeah
good one oh look at this look at that I
don't know what's going on but you know
ah it's awesome wow
you're just making slime
the Doom guy and should write a comic
have this thing auto-generate the art
for you yeah start just a new genre of
art man so wait these images it
generates aren't yours to use for real
yeah so we when we do news stories we
can just be like it I think it depends
on the specific model but it probably
freaked people out I'm pretty sure that
you have the rights if they're so scroll
down does it say anything like yeah I
think it should say yeah read it
creativeml open see that every model has
no rights it says no rights
oh look at this what is that what the is
that what's the prompt here Elon Musk as
the Doom guy oh that's creepy wow Elon
Musk buying Twitter I don't like that
come on you can do it
there we go while we're waiting let's
actually read the license I want to see
what you actually have the ability to do
forbid you from the content that
violates any laws
they claim no rights your freedom as a
as and are accountable for their use
there you go this just spawned a genre
this is amazing so now for all of our
news articles when it's like Joe Biden
does something we'll type in and just
use it pulse look at this poles pulses
look at this
I love how there's always like for some
reason two of them like elon's
interviewing Elon huh yeah it's like the
Persona they do like the Persona of Elon
and Elon himself I think I wonder if
that's what the AI is doing I would say
that we'd use this for like Tim cast
thumbnails but they're so creepy sure I
think it would terrify people and they
wouldn't want to share them yeah it's
like no I'd prefer not to use the
nightmare images for my news I've typed
in Bill Gates with sexy body it did not
it could not satisfy it's not I don't
know if there's any I mean it shows his
body full and it's not sexy no no but
it's just crazy this is brand new I mean
this came out like in the last couple
months it's it's so this is just the
beginning I mean in within a year it's
gonna be someone's gonna release like
150 comics in like two weeks because
they're gonna have all this art done for
them Elon Musk returning to his home
planet
come on
oh I know I've got I've got it
I know what we're gonna do after this
one I hope you guys are ready
no and then we'll grab the Super Chat
ones because this is the weirdest we get
addicted to these things last time we
did the same thing happened it's just
too funny like you want you want to see
more like I want to know what the
machine can do Elon Musk returning to
his home planet here we go
soon
okay here we go I like the spaceship one
in the bottom right yeah that's great
Jeff Bezos Mark Zuckerberg and what I
spelled Zuckerberg really wrong
Zuckerberg and
um
who else do we got in there we got Bezos
we got Zuck at Bill Gates and Bill Gates
fused into one person
do that it's a triumvirate okay it's the
three-headed snake the but the in the
future you'll be you'll be asking
permission of bersucker gates we'll try
them for it do the admins on hugging
face they're going what is happening
right now
it's got like red alert in their slack
Channel they're like oh wake up we got
hugging face
ready
oh he's just tall guy okay it does kind
of look like Zucker and Gates Summit
like it does
Amazon Factory yeah this is like this
this the ear the most eerily accurate
image yet so far there's no face but
it's kind of like
oh that's scary didn't even try the face
yeah so uh how about we actually I think
there will be certain models that can
generate like Ben Shapiro's stuff that
will feel more like cartoons they could
do cartoons they'll be cartoon specifics
they'll be influencers that are totally
AI generated that are not real they
tried that yeah and and they will do it
if they haven't done it already geez I
was watching a whole Army of them
working for you exactly or influencing
social media for their for a particular
cause
um you know just like Bots yeah puppet
accounts I was watching uh gameplay
footage last night and I watched some
Japanese game and all these like anime
avatars instead of people streaming
their face it was a bunch of cartoon
anime avatars over top of like filters
so I can see a guy building those Ben
Shapiro playing tennis that's a good one
Ben Shapiro
angry after losing tennis match
all right why is he wearing a kilt that
was cool was he wearing a kilt yeah it
was like a redstone oh I got a good one
after this uh Jordan Peterson playing
bagpipes I just want to see it man one
time just one time just gotta see it
somebody said AI self-portrait which
would be really cool what do you look
like yeah yes so tell us
all right here we go Lori Lightfoot look
at this oh yeah Ben Shapiro angry after
losing tennis match
huh well there you go it's pretty
awesome uh oh yeah image of
your
self dream yeah I think it does really
well with non-people like I typed in
psychedelic space mushroom I have a
feeling it's going to be really
beautiful bizarre or not free what if we
like ask the AI like your deepest desire
and it shows an image of just like dead
humans
we'll be like uh maybe we should turn it
off it'll just start playing the
Terminator yeah it's just a picture of
yeah TT what was it two thousand one
thousand T-1000 yeah
here we go it's it's going image of your
dream what's it going to look like
what
uh one more one more artificial
intelligence
uh AI self-portrait yes psychedelic
space space mushrooms super cool
psychedelic space so much weird looking
colorful art oh yeah that's that's what
it is that's nice sure is yeah dude the
internet's so interesting that it can
Source data so quickly
like people's faces
so but how do they do this is it like it
pre-loaded tons of images already like
going up to a certain year and then whoa
look at that
so I hope this one's okay this one is
the creepiest Christopher Walken on
Earth what is that
welcome to the Future ladies and
gentlemen it is creepy don't like it
very much like a dream all right man
well you know we should do let's let's
let's now that we've spent 40 minutes
talking about this that was fun we've
just done let's uh we gotta talk about
this with new uh with uh Matt Walsh blog
we have this tweet from Nuance bro and
he says this is how you do it folks all
right so let me give you some backstory
these uh Media Matters types are digging
up old comments and videos from Matt
Walsh when he had like a radio show when
he was younger they're taking them out
of context and trying to smear and
defame Matt Walsh and it's just it's
stupid there was one video they shared
where it's Matt Walsh and his friend
joking about burning a book and being
and like being Nazis or whatever but it
was funny because they couldn't get the
lighters to work and they were like just
wait until rednecks figure out fire and
they're like trying to light a book on
fire it was funny so in response to the
smear campaign against Matt Walsh he
responded by saying this
so here's my official answer
for the record
um
kiss my ass
I do not apologize
in fact by All rights you sick freaks
should be the ones apologizing to me for
lying and defaming me and doing it all
because I'm trying to prevent you from
sexually mutilating children
you damned monsters
you child abusing Psychopaths
I wouldn't apologize to you soulless
parasites if I had a gun to my head
dude and so I'd rather just tell you all
to piss off
I apologize for nothing I concede
nothing
I Will Never Surrender even a single
inch of ground to a pitchfork mob of
degenerate morons
[Laughter]
you know the secret they never say out
loud is that nobody is truly canceled
unless they consent to it correct and
they willingly play their assigned roles
well I do not consent
and I'm not going to play the game
I'm not going anywhere
that was absolutely amazing and that's
how it's done
that's how you do it folk says Nuance
Pro and that is that's it right there I
don't like the name calling though
that that I like Matt a lot but calling
people like insults is just inflaming I
think it's just inflamming if he really
wants to lower tension I mean if he
wants to these are people who have
intentionally taken audio from him out
of context and then lied about him to
try and cause damage to his work when
he's trying to help kids when he said
that I'm trying to stop you from
mutilating children I get that because
he is but when he calls them like
gratuitously morons and things like that
I don't know I can understand not
wanting to insult someone in a general
context of a political argument but this
is different these are people who are
acting outside the bounds of moralian
Ethics they are seeking to manipulate
and lie to people for political power
what would you be calling them out yeah
what would you say what would be your
response uh so your met loss you're
remaking this video go I would have
taken one of them no no go you're on I
know I'm talking to I'd be talking to an
individual I would say their name and
directly talk to them as if they were
sitting in front of me
an organization published a video who do
you respond to the CEO okay there you go
okay so what did I say
um you're well I mean Mr Poopy Pants
first we gotta figure out who said it I
mean if it's what is it like what who's
the organization I don't know the the
specifics but I would talk to an
individual that's a big part of it is
you name them you talk to them as if
they're there they listen and they hear
that and they're like okay he's actually
talking to me now I'm trying to
understand there was someone who uh came
to one of our events and lied
and uh a leftist smear Merchant and
light and so I politely responded on
Twitter with like hey this thing you're
saying didn't actually happen I hope we
can resolve this and they responded with
something like I hope a bird craps on
your face and so I went okay I guess I
was at an event a political event and
the person who who in founded this this
organization was on stage and so I asked
hey you say that your organization is
engaged in truth-telling in fact I think
when I when one of your uh you know
reporters posted uh verifiably false
statements about me and I asked for a
correction politely they said they
wished a burger crap on my face and it
says whatever ignored me and walked off
then you gotta go to the to the
individual that said they want the crap
on your face I talk directly to them in
a video by name Ian that's how you do it
you confront people and they love the
drama the crowd this is why people like
what Matt Walsh did because the problem
we face in the culture war is that
whatever this faction is constantly
tries to be nice kind of I would not be
nice to the person I would directly
confront them but them an individual
that this is my point they are burning
down pregnancy centers they're
firebombing them and then lying about
what the pregnancy centers do they are
lying about Matt Walsh and for for the
longest time you get people like with
you know with all due respect when we
had
um
why am I forgetting Rick Santorum on the
show and he's like no no no we got a
billy by the rules play by the rules and
I'm like yo they're burning down
buildings and we're not even saying do
that we're saying the law enforcement
should be dealing with it but at the
very least we don't just say I'm so
sorry let's be nice to them we say these
are evil awful people who are burning
down buildings what they what they were
trying to do with Matt Walsh was accuse
him of of being a child abuser because
of out of context comments from from 15
years ago who is it is it just text
comments that were insulting he was on a
radio show and he said something about
he said something like throughout
history women got pregnant at much
younger ages and now in today's day and
age they're saying it's a mistake if
women do but that's only because we
decided that I don't know the full
context I just know that they're taking
these things out of context which is why
he said outright you are seek you are
lying to defame me and I will not
apologize to you for it so look we
constantly have people saying like hey
why don't we invite this person to come
on the show question how come none of
the prominent leftists will come on on
the show and sit down and have a
conversation some will but they tend to
have smaller following they're trying to
establish themselves but for the most
part they don't and then what happens
when we do have some of these people on
they smack the microphone and freak out
and get angry yeah I make videos to
those people directly with their name
and I look at the camera while I'm
talking to them and you can humiliate
them to their face via video and
everyone gets to watch it doesn't do
anything oh it does a lot I used to do
it in the I mean it's pretty aggro but
you can definitely Shake someone by
doing that so so you have people who
make videos and comment on that all day
and night Matt Walsh came out and said
he smacked him back he he he
made it personal
and people are happy that he did because
people are sick this is why people voted
for Trump because for the longest time
you get people again I appreciate Rick
said to him coming on but his attitude
of being very deferential and saying
we're the ones who are going to play by
the rules it's like okay if you're
playing a game Monopoly and the person
sitting across the table is literally
cheating in front of you and you're like
well you're cheating and they go and are
you gonna keep playing I guess we better
play by the rules okay they're not but
you sit there anyway it's it makes no
sense so this is where he's finally
saying this is the sentiment that people
have been feeling for a long time I
don't care anymore you don't matter to
me you people are awful you are sick
they they killed people in the Summer of
Love they burned down buildings they uh
what they're doing to kids it's just all
abhorrent and I'm actually I'm very very
happy today that when I see this stuff I
know that I don't have to fear them and
Matt Walsh doing this give providing the
statement saying I would not apologize
to you parasites if there was a gun to
my head showing how successful that is
that he can do that that we don't have
to bend the knee to a psychopathic cult
it is freeing that we we're not trying
to be mean we're trying to be nice we're
trying to we're trying to solve problems
and we're trying to find a path forward
and what do we get instead bricks
through the window lies manipulations
and a refusal to to have a con
conversation
they stop Ben Shapiro from going to
events and speaking they stop Ann
Coulter from doing it they they spray
painted a death threat to liberals when
milianopolis tried to speak at an event
where where are the conservatives
burning down universities not happening
so at a certain point there is a group
of people saying you know what we don't
want what they're doing we don't want
violence we don't want retaliation but
you don't matter to us anymore at all
uh I don't know that Matt definitely
seems concerned if they didn't matter to
him he wouldn't have responded so Matt
doesn't talk about this very often but I
am sure that his entire family all six
of his children two of them unborn and
his poor wife are undoubtedly under
constant threat from these absolute
soulless monsters these are people who
will stop at nothing they will come to
your house it will break your windows
they will insult you if you go to try to
defend yourself they will get you
arrested they will call the cops on you
they will use the State against you they
arrested something like 11 old pro-life
protesters just for the crime of being
at a pro-life protest they will use
everything in the books their game is
power they talk about it all the time
because it's what they're going for and
they accuse the right of wanting it
because it's what they want more than
anything else and when they have power
they will not give you anything back
they don't care about your freedom of
speech and all he did was insult them
right there was a riot on January 20th
2017 where I mean you were there right
Luke we were both yes right I got I got
I got arrested you got away yeah I I
there's a huge line of Riot cops I
pushed right through them and got pepper
sprayed right in the face they were
forming a line and so I pulled I flanked
left to try and get away out of the
Riders Luke went forward and then the
cops boxed in the left area and then all
the Riders surrounded me but I I ended
up getting getting out because I had a
press credential these people
not only did they have the charges
dropped after they were smashing windows
and setting fire to Vehicles they
destroyed the the livelihood of an
immigrant who had leased a limo to do it
to be it to be a to uh to run a company
as a driver they set his limo on fire
the cops that were unable to do anything
about it these people got arrested
and then after they were released and
the charges were dropped they filed a
lawsuit against the city and won and the
city paid them money and that's what
we've been dealing with for what a
decade now so for the longest time you
don't see there is a zero percent
probability that Matt Walsh's followers
storm a university to shut down these
speakers and that's actually really
funny because Matt says I'm trying to
stop you from harming kids and they
won't even protest you know to a certain
degree
obviously there are people that are
going out and protesting what I'm saying
is on the scale that the left is engaged
in this level of violence the right goes
nowhere near and and all we're getting
is Matt Walsh being like you are sick
degenerates and you're saying like oh
that's bad he shouldn't do that okay
well I can certainly understand why
you'd feel that way but you should
understand why people are like they burn
down a building and we've insulted them
and you're mad at him if you want to
disperse a mob you got to shake one
individual up psychologically in yelling
expletives if the crowd doesn't fix the
problem which is the mob is insane this
is the point you take one of them you
make an example out of them by insult by
basically humiliating them in front of
the crowd and the crowd's like oh I
don't want to be Associated when they
refuse to come on these shows if you
make an internet video directly to them
yeah but Ian you're sort of saying like
don't be mean but then be mean I'm not
saying don't be it's not just that it's
like you're saying scream into the wind
no do you make an internet you
especially you right now you make an
internet video talking to somebody watch
the video you don't know that if someone
hears their name on the Internet they're
going to that video
what they do and this is like the
perfect example is The Young Turks
instead of actually watching the segment
or maybe they do they just watch a clip
from some propaganda Channel and or at
the very least they watch it and then
lie about it
like every single time The Young Turks
has done a segment about something I've
said they've lied about what the context
of the conversation was for example we
had a conversation recently where I said
something effective I'm sure most women
are happy to have careers and engage in
work I'm sure some of them however
probably end up regretting it wishing
they had families and what they did was
they took that Twisted it and claimed I
thought I was saying something like
women just want to be wives and have
babies which is not what I said didn't
change approach you one time screaming
at me and yeah what was the lunacy right
nuts they made a they made a smear piece
about Dave Rubin and they put my name
front and center for some reason and I
saw a Jank at political I was like hey
man how's it going I just I was trying
to get in touch with you I've been
messaging you you didn't respond but you
guys put up a video that like it was
about Dave Rubin or something but my
name was on it so I was just hoping I
could ask you like just in the future
how to do that and then he just started
screaming you're a trump supporter and
this was in like 2017 or something just
started screaming at me I don't remember
what he was saying that time and I was
like why are you yelling at me and then
a bunch of journalists random start
filming and they're like what happened
I'm like I have no idea I was like dude
when nuts are screaming at me these
people have lost their minds dude I've
known Jank for a long time I remember
seeing him at VidCon and being like hey
I was like a shaking sound I've been in
a show a couple times and then one day I
go to him and I'm like hey you guys did
like they were making fun of Dave Rubin
or something and they used a report that
had Tim Poole in their thumbnail like
right in the middle and I I messaged
Jacob I was like hey man I was like you
made a video and it's got my name on it
but it's about Dave Rubin I'm just you
know he ignored me I messaged Anna who I
also have known for a long time and they
ignored me and then now they just make
weird smear pieces like there's no point
in trying to have a conversation with
people who will never come and have a
conversation well I think it's there's a
point in trying and eventually you know
you can get through it just because you
guys are talking like right now what's
happening is you're talking past each
other you talk about them they talk
about you message them I'm talking about
internet video communicate there used to
be video responses on YouTube the whole
point was you make a video to someone
then they answer you back and talk to
you there's communication people get to
listen and watch and then they start to
mimic the behavior yeah why do you think
YouTube removed videos Google bought it
and they don't understand social
networking
and I first met I did a video response
to Ian that was that's how we first met
look man
you know knowing these people for like a
decade and then one day Ian's screaming
in my face in public and my response to
that is still consistently to politely
invite him for a conversation you said
Ian chank chank sorry sorry I wouldn't
do that to you baby that makes you like
far away I need you to hear me I'll be
in five years knowing knowing this guy
for as long as I have having polite
conversations appearing on a show on
more than one occasion then one day
abruptly and for no reason he starts
screaming in my face in public I made a
video about him like I have no idea what
happened I have no idea why he's
screaming at me I'm not Alex Jones I
don't have any beef with him I've never
argued with him before I've never had a
negative word about him he just started
screaming at me in public cameras
everywhere they're filming it and I'm
like what's happening I was like why are
you yelling at me and then even after
that I still politely say we'd love to
have you on the show at any time we'll
cover all costs I know that's a great
position but he they never they will
never do it never because they are not
genuine people this is why when Matt
Walsh says you are degenerate morons
people are cheering for it because for
too long we have tried to politely just
be like can we please talk and resolve
this and they say no we're going to burn
your city down we're gonna beat your
elderly we're going to try and kill Kyle
Rittenhouse you're talking about a lot
of different people though I'm talking
about all of these people aligned with
this movement this cult this ideology
for whatever reason and and there's
various subcultures within it but for
some reason all of them refuse to have a
conversation a small handful will have a
conversation Jimmy Dore who's basically
an outright socialist is called far
right it's it's nonsensical cult
meaninglessness I wonder if he's changed
because he actually spat in Alex's face
on one yeah and then we were there
Young Turks were doing this sit down at
was it the RNC right RNC in Cleveland
and and Alex came up laughing and
talking to them while they were doing
their thing and they got mad Jimmy spit
on Alex we were standing right there it
was crazy they're like what the hell's
going on here so look I can understand
but now Jimmy actually supports Free
Speech which is great well he's always
supported free stuff yeah but like
having a seems like obscene Behavior
sure sure look I I think what Jimmy did
in that context was was wrong but I
think there's a difference between
someone coming and interrupting your
live shot so you're having a personal
beef with them and whether or not you
support free speech like I don't think
it's inherently free speech that someone
walks up to you during your show and
starts trying to interrupt it you know
what I mean that's that's a different
question but but sure Jimmy should not
have got baited in spam or whatever I I
think Jimmy has consistently called out
the establishment the Democrats and what
he encounters is all of a sudden people
are blindly marching in lockstep behind
them and he's like since when since when
have we supported this machine this
corporate Democrat machine and they're
like your right wing he's like what I
did see a segment of Anna and chank you
know pushing back against the defund the
police so it's not all one group no no
you know this is funny though you're
right they recently and I gave him
credit for it yeah came out saying
defund the place is stupid but you know
they've very heavily supported it
so yeah they were tweet I saw a certain
things right a bunch of tweets came out
and so people were like they supported
this now look change your mind exactly
and that's why I'm like that good on
them but the issue is it's it's
politically expedient defund the police
has become unpopular they are following
the polls that's it
if anything I have all the reason in the
world to just keep doubling down and
being like Trump's the best Trump's the
best instead I'm like I don't know man
Rhonda Santas maybe and then why is he
saying why is Trump saying death penalty
for drug dealers right that is insane
why like just don't so this but we can
break this down first yeah I don't I
disagree with the death penalty outright
second however
most people interpret that as
specifically having to do with
traffickers of like heroin and opioids
and things like that or if you're lacing
stuff with Fenton right right not like
someone's slinging pot and the other
argument is that when it comes to those
things these people have killed dozens
hundreds or more so but be specific like
don't make statements like that you have
to be targeted in your language no and
that's Trump yeah that's just right so I
I that's why you know when I look at uh
there's there's some tweets right now
someone tweeted at me Will Chamberlain
it was it was an amazing show we had
here with a handful of people and you
know Will Chamberlain said something
like he actually thinks the FED is good
and then everyone else goes like ah no
but like it's like the most shockingly
offensive thing you can say to anybody
in this room but Will's great we love
having well in the show even though we
completely disagree on that and then we
have uh ilad aliyahu who reports for it
for timcast and he's talking about how
he supports military intervention
because he wants a monopolar world with
the US charge and we got really into it
I was yelling I had to apologize and uh
but we think he's fantastic we com we
disagree to the point where we were like
really angry and I was like this is I
was pissed
um but I think he's I think he does an
amazing job and I think you know we're
glad to have those conversations
but there's that group of people that
claim to be the left they will not come
on they will not talk and for some
reason their opinions flow with the wind
as however the polls are suggesting It's
amazing And whatever is the popular
group think I mean we even disagree we
have debates on this show and and iron
sharpens iron it's great to have those
conversations it's great to challenge
yourself it's great to actually question
things instead of just like hey this is
what people want me to say I'm just
going to say it because I want to be
liked and that's where a lot of these
people come from this is kind of group
heard sheep mentality and this is why
you never bend the knee to the the
Pitchfork mob this is why you never
acquiesce to everyone in the status quo
is going along with because if you're
doing that you're just degressing
yourself when we should be challenging
ourselves we should be questioning
ourselves we should be of course always
going up to Authority and saying not
today you SOB because you deserve some
accountability some transparency and you
deserve to be questioned outright with
what you're doing with the power that
you have power should always be
challenged these people are just trying
to get as much as they can for
themselves and and truly screwing
everyone and giving a disservice not
only to Their audience but also to
themselves by doing this so question
everything and and this is why I liked I
I liked what I saw with Matt Walsh
because it's come it comes from that
energy like I'm not going to do what you
tell me to do I'm not going to say two
plus two equals five and this is why a
lot of people seeing this from from Matt
Walsh today I don't agree with
everything that Matt has to say or think
but when he came out with this message
it was a resounding Fu to anyone in the
establishment anyone trying to control
him and and that's something that I want
to see more of I think the never
apologize idea is generally true
assuming like never apologize you know
for uh your principles never go back
against your principles but the idea of
never apologizing is a blanket statement
makes no sense like you should apologize
when you want to apologize and your core
principles tell you that that's the
appropriate thing to do I loved when he
was just like by all accounts you should
be apologizing to me yeah so he
acknowledges that apologies are needed
sometimes yeah yeah that was good yeah
you know what man
I think I think he hit a home run and
and the more to the point is you have
people who go on Twitter who lie trying
to people find from their jobs this was
one of those circumstances I a lot of
people have you know come out and been
like I'm so sorry you're angry with me
and they still lose their jobs Matt
Walsh hey look the daily wire is not
going to fire Matt Walsh over this
they're going to be laughing about it
and he gets the opportunity to come out
and say this by doing so it is a stake
in the heart of the cancel culture mob I
don't think it's a home run but I do
think he bunted with a guy on third who
made it home and scored a run but he got
thrown out at first so you know they're
still down by one run very specific for
bottle analogy nice move maybe you could
have got there faster but I think he's
you know not he lets you know his anger
it was an angry response and anger is a
very dangerous tool I'll accept that
with another a rebuttal analogy that
Matt Walsh is Paving the way for more
people to stand up against cancel
culture and if that means the runaround
third made it home because of what he
did then I agree with you yeah he's
doing a lot of good and not not
everything has to be all good or all bad
I think that the fact that he's bringing
attention to child mutilation of any
kind is important like if you're going
to get a kid's a 13 year old's boobs cut
off and stitched up like yo we got to
really consider what that means as a
culture yeah and he is clearly trying to
have the conversation with people he
disagrees with I mean that's what his
whole movie was doing he was trying to
find people to have you know
conversations and to debate the issue so
he wants to have the debate and he's
willing to talk to anybody his his
delivery is is the best it's very just
dry and very calm I love when they said
that when he was talking with a Little
Mermaid and he said that she should have
translucent face and look like a
nightmare skeleton floating around the
depths or whatever and they were like
LGBT Nation or whatever wrote that he
was having a meltdown and I'm just like
anybody who's ever watched Matt Walsh
knows that that's not possible his
meltdown is just him going like this
that was him out there right it's him
being like I will not apologize to you
you morons like this it's like not
particularly you'll have to rip my heart
for my body all right we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and become a member at
timcast.com because your membership
keeps all of our journalists employed
keeps our shows up and running and we're
hearing a lot of really great things
about the cast Castle Vlog people are
really really loving it uh Ian did an
excellent job oh shout out to Wesley
Goble and Chris Poole for producing and
writing that thing and you too as an
executive producer I I love the
direction that it's going it's it's
ridiculous fun nonsense but you know it
it is it is it's still early so you were
mentioning the other day like you're
trying to get sound quality improvements
and and all that stuff you know you
shoot on different days so you have
different lighting schemes so when you
have like a portable lighting scheme and
sometimes we shoot at different times of
day so we'll get different lighting
outside you can balance that stuff out
in post or with the right technology
sometimes we have a special guest coming
next week to film and I'm just so
excited for this for the plot line of
this I hope it's executed right because
the the jokes as they've been written
are some of the funniest and most
offensive things ever it's going to be
amazing maybe it's not the most
offensive thing ever it's just like it's
it's designed to be you know
well I don't know edgy I guess yeah I
want to talk about edgy stuff in a
compelling way that grandmas and
seven-year-olds can enjoy wow
not this one bring levity to these
intense conversations so everyone can
have them let's grab some super chats we
got Frank Rizzo he says hey Tim and crew
long time listener and member you should
try to figure out how to broadcast on
shortwave radio the world will hear your
show is that like local radio stations
and stuff
yeah I think you can just get get a
device here I think it's like Pirate
Radio no I don't know about doing
anything like that you got to get like
an FCC bandwidth air like you gotta buy
an area on the bandwidth I know probably
worth it get on am
shortwave yeah and would be great yeah
all right I'll lighten enlighten me with
Ronnie I can't read the last part
podcast so say Tim have a great chat
I've uh I've been up too late when you
are live first ever Super Chat really do
appreciate that Super Chat
scrotes My Goats says it's my birthday
and I have no desire to celebrate feels
like I'm watching The Apocalypse play
out right before my eyes
well one way to uh get ahead of all this
bill
you gotta take a lot of money invest in
a company that makes pots
and Cricket food they are telling you
these things
so it's just like you know look at the
beginning of the pandemic Trump's like
we're gonna get a vaccine if you
invested in modern at that point bought
moderna stock jumped like what 400 or
something
some ridiculous number don't feed the
beast don't give them your money that's
not voting with your dollars
invest pot companies no
no get farmer contacted me said that it
requires 1500 pounds of corn and soy to
feed 250 pounds of crickets so you're
getting what is that a one to five so
you're basically eating corn soy yes
essentially shocking yeah 11 but you're
getting protein out of it and for the
person who just had their birthday happy
birthday try to enjoy the little things
in life and not try to be overwhelmed by
the world's burdens and enjoy the
friends the family the people you have
around you I'm just saying you know no
don't listen don't do that it's got to
be open source these pods because
they're gonna be tracking your
Biometrics
all right all right we'll try and grab
some more super jets
Topher Studio says I've been subscribed
to Luke for over a year but I won't
watch his videos because of how
clickbait the thumbnails are it's not
2016. make them serious not silly
clickbait love you though you don't tell
me what to do what I want I'm gonna make
a more click baby I'm gonna use that AI
tool right now and even make them worse
off than you thought Bob
Daryl line says YouTube Shenanigans
again had to reload the stream three
times to get audio to load
yep funny how that works
crispy Joe says shaking my head YouTube
not notifying me again I have video
proof where do I send the link
I think it was Shadow band at
timcast.com I don't remember all to
double check before we come back for
next week because we were like we told
people if they had evidence of this to
send it to us we're going to go through
it because if someone was suggesting if
we can show a pattern of behavior then
there's a there's a detriment YouTube is
not providing you know the proper
release well this one because I heard
you on your other stream it's like is
the shadow Banner Shadow band you should
just do both so
oh yeah just copying Shadow ban Shadow
bands Shadow band there you go there we
go Shadows band Shadow's band no nothing
Shadows band
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
after you're sad AF 4pm I stopped at
Weiss clerks Clerk's eyes screamed at
sadness me banks hope you are well him
I'm here me at least you're alive
breathing him unfortunately I felt bad
for him wow what was your segment about
uh 23 year old was euthanized in Belgium
for being depressed yeah
and it was like she she survived a
terror attack and so she said she had
PTSD and wanted to die and so they're
like okay and then the family sat around
her as they gave her the medication and
she smiled and then died oh my God and
that's what nightmares has she been
physically injured other than just the
trauma nope
they were she was on like 10 different
medications oh wow yeah and it's just
like well that's probably what's what's
breaking her brain maybe that's the
problem maybe maybe you know all the
medical interventions we have making the
problems worse statistically aren't
helping yeah maybe ignoring the problem
for so long didn't actually solve it
maybe not focusing on health or diet or
exercise or daily activities mattered
all right pinochet's helicopter tour
says I've got two words for you let's go
Brandon
that's a good one good work
what do we got here
oh where are we at
Caroline says Biden saved us from World
War III just like he brought down gas
prices yeah
everybody is saying this I know Don
Diego says guys I think he was saying
Maiden America like like a maiden yeah
like it was two words that's what that
PolitiFact Is going to do it's gonna be
like he did say two words made in
America it was a reference to me do AI
art for Maiden for the made in America
see what she looks like oh yeah so what
is it you can download the program to
your own computer
someone was saying that so let's try
different apps that can run the engine
yeah because then you don't got to worry
about the queue or whatever you can just
yeah and like I I'd be interested in
trying to generate images for thumbnails
like if you can get one that's not scary
or creepy unless you wanted it to be oh
we should totally use that for Shane's
new show
hey Shane Cashman yeah man great idea
because it it naturally just makes
everything look horrifying and
nightmarish even normal stuff yeah even
normal stuff so it feels like a story
about an apple it'll make it look creepy
there you go
yo can we answer from Super mines made
in Americas oh you want to answer some
yeah I mean if you want a shout out yeah
so guys we just launched this new
product it's called supermind what it's
like super chat it's half the fees so
you know more of your money's going to
Tim the Creator you basically can go to
mines.com timcast click the supermind
button ask him a question and you don't
pay unless he answers so it's basically
an offer and if he answers he can answer
it on stream he can answer it during the
week yeah you can do all these different
types of responses so there's some in
there it'd be cool to be cool I'll jump
over in a second all right I do like so
here's the thing with super chats people
have already paid and they have comments
and we try to read as many as we can
right with super Minds you offer to pay
and if we don't read it you don't pay
right so there there is a there's a
balance I try to do because I don't I
don't you know some people are like why
won't Tim read the the big Super Chat
and I'm like I do appreciate the big
super chats I do want to read as many as
I can but I also don't want people who
can't afford to send a tons of money to
to become out and so we tried his
readable yeah small ones are green the
last thing I would say is that like for
people you know that's kind of the bad
part about super chats you don't
necessarily get a response so people who
you know money is tight these days so to
know that you're gonna get a response
from a Creator is a big deal
all right Falcon Legend says Tim this
weekend you need to watch the movie
threads on YouTube it is a British made
movie about what the aftermath of a
nuclear war would be like there's also a
show in the BBC I've not yet watched
called years and years I think it's
called have you heard of this no and
it's it's like a show that was meant to
I guess mock Trump or something and it's
like about a populist who wins and then
starts advocating for immigrant genocide
or something like that I don't know I
gotta I gotta watch it but you know
something that's probably cringe but I'm
interested in watching threads though
that sounds pretty cool 1984 TV show is
that what it is yeah
cleft the misfit says think think what
happened to Dorsey with Twitter is like
what happened to Trump in office
staff the organization with snakes and
ideologues who hampered him instead of
helped him
perhaps but Dorsey left Twitter and then
came back it was a was it dick Costello
was the CEO for a while and then what
did he do he wrote uh Silicon Valley or
something
was that a book no the TV show on HBO oh
no Costello wrote that yeah I think he
was involved in that I thought somebody
would like judge right and I'm pretty
sure well
you want to look it up yeah he's got
some credit in there doesn't he yeah
they probably had all kinds of
Consultants from the valley but I think
at like a significant writing for
Silicon Valley I don't know what he did
exactly writing for the show oh he's an
ex-comedian I didn't write that and then
he became the CEO it's an accurate show
to be honest dick cost solo improv comic
in Chicago
all right
Louis Aguilar says hi Liz I'm here for
the scandalous announcement I wish you
good things on your new production
I don't think that I have a super
scandalous announcement I will just say
goodbye like I always do for the last
time which is a little bit sad but life
goes on and it'll be good yeah this is
it this is your last show that's right
it's my last show well last show here
replacement last year you're actually
you have a new show don't you on
Saturday mornings
um I don't have anything set in stone
we're still figuring it out but we're
going to be trying to make a difference
in the culture as we go forward and you
guys can check it out later right on
Boom Aaron tamiki says bye Linda I'm
gonna miss you on the show since you are
leaving what was your favorite moment
from the show and who was your favorite
guest oh my gosh my favorite guest was
definitely Ed Calderon he's fantastic he
used to be a cop down in Tijuana and he
has crazy stories you guys aren't
familiar with him you should check out
Ed's Manifesto on Instagram my favorite
moment from the show that had me
paralyzed was probably when ra smacked
the microphone that was scary for me I
was like what is happening what's gonna
happen next so yeah probably a lot of
people have in common but it's really
interesting moments like that he hung
out for a little bit afterwards we
invited him back yeah he felt bad about
it afterwards yeah he apologized we
hugged it out that's cool you're welcome
you're welcome oh yeah okay Luke yeah
look at him
all right what about Immortal Technique
he'd be cool to have on right I'll ask
him I think he'll be great but we
probably have political disagreements
right probably uh but it'll be great to
to talk it out what about him and Alex
Jones they had a conversation before so
they met together and they had a video
interview I think you know I know we
need to do we need to have this table
set up with a person from each of the
political quadrants on the political
Compass there you go yeah yeah good idea
yeah I I have like the themed rooms with
each color just have the same color well
we'll just like we'll put play we'll put
mats of the colors well we did uh red we
did our test right and we're like almost
opposite each other on the bottom left
Center libertarian with Luke on the
right quadrant yeah one point and me on
the left quadrant one yeah so so we
would be in that same kind of position
and we Ian would be uh where would you
be um
I kind of play that role and I do have a
kind of an authoritarian bet so so yeah
and then we need like a super commie I
mean we can get real authoritarians on
the show that'd be interesting
I'm pretty far left relative to you guys
I was like halfway to the left and
halfway to the bottom
all right halfway through that quadrant
how do I uh
I want to answer a uh a super mind yeah
but I need to know
I don't have the URL to the stream no
just just type in answered on stream
that's right okay answered on episode
yeah what are we 632 32 bam all right in
the super mind this is from oh I can't
say the name of the user right now
Raymundo why do you think Elon has
suddenly decided to go through with a
Twitter deal at the original offer price
after months of seemingly trying to get
out of it do you think the deal goes
through and will Twitter actually change
so I have talked about this before I
think
um
he did try to negotiate a price down we
were asking this for like why didn't you
try to get a cheaper deal he did he
tried getting 30 off they said no he
tried saying okay what about 10 they
said no and then he finally said okay
fine we'll do it my my attitude is I
think there's an element of he's going
to lose in court I think there's also an
element of when he said no to World War
III and the Bots bombarded his Paul and
favored War he was probably just like
okay I have to do this you know net
worth be damned but it was a reasonable
argument that the Bots are a high
percentage of Twitter and also the
Whistleblower came out and it seems like
nothing's really coming of The
Whistleblower saying that he was trying
to get the Bots taken care of and who's
The Whistleblower the their head of
security
Twitter's head of security came out and
said that there's just all of these
unacceptable practices he'd be a great
company guest on this she would be a
great guy you know what his name is uh
just if you just look up Twitter
whistlebar I forget his name all right
did we confirm the supermind did the
payment go through oh oh I don't know I
just yeah yeah I mean yeah I went
through there's a bunch and they're like
it's a lot of money or something like
120 bucks 250 bucks we blew it up
earlier to get people to pull right on
yeah so all right here we got one um max
Reddit with the Super Chat he says Kim
yeah
it's hilarious please keep doing this
also we miss Sheamus is she coming back
uh at some point I imagine I hope so
Sheamus who is that I have no idea is
that like somebody's dog yeah wow okay
that's not who you're talking good one
Ian I like that yeah I misspoke rude I
love you Seamus here we go dork tanning
says how are you sure that some Tesla
employee in California isn't trying to
make your death look like a traffic
accident
like people people like I try and tell
them like when it comes to having a lot
of followers on these on social media
platforms yeah again notifications yeah
turn them off yeah at certain point I
just whatever yeah
282
925. you know what's cool I didn't
actually didn't know this but we have
like 300 000 Subs on Rumble too Tim
castor oil and we and and so does my Tim
cast Channel but my Tim pool channel for
some reason only has like 70. so I was
like let's just put all those all my
personal show videos on the Tim cast one
with 300K Subs that's that's that's
amazing rumble's doing a great job and
then on mines as well all of my tweets
go up there yeah dude the videos do too
right yep I don't know yep it looks like
you got a little a small one from for 22
you can do tokens too but is there a
game that you're enjoying Let's do let's
do this and we'll uh answered on episode
632 IRL we're gonna update this FYI in
the future so you can just respond
instantly for super for the live stream
use case so they'll be able to say
because uh that they want you to answer
on stream you just click once but what
if you go through and you don't respond
to anything and you say yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes live and you take all
this money and you don't respond no you
have well it's it's definitely there's
good it's definitely based on the honor
System generally
um I mean they could Super Chat you have
the money that's the thing super it's
already better than super it's more in
the fans interest to do a super mine
than Super Chat because their chance of
getting a sponsor higher is there a game
you're really enjoying these days I play
one video game and it's Spiel and Q2 and
I'm currently mapping the Spelunky
Multiverse so uh for those that are
familiar with Spelunky 2. it's a
roguelike game where you enter into a
cave and you go down various levels and
then at the end you actually go on a
rocket ship up to uh hundun's world or
whatever it's called I don't know and
then there's a cosmic ocean I don't care
about the cosmic ocean at all for those
of familiar with the game what I'm doing
is once you unlock seeds you can
actually type in an alphanumeric code
which will give you a specific
generation so the game is randomly
generated procedurally generated every
every new game is different but if you
if you if you unlock seed seated runs
you can actually enter a code it's I
think it's like I don't know how many
digits it is 10 or something
so what I've been doing I started with
world one two three I'm on uh
252 right now so I've I've played
through that many games like and there's
a bunch more I've probably played
thousands of games of Spelunky
ridiculous I hope you called the
Spelunky verse
Spelunky Multiverse yeah just the
spelunk Versa but there's also uh
there's zero through nine and then a b
uh a b c d e f so there's a lot of
potential World Generations in this game
and so I'm just going with numbers so
I'm I'm I've played up to world 253. so
I'm actually just going zero zero zero
one zero zero two zero zero three and
then I'm up to 253. you beat them all
all you beat one no not beat them all
played played through them to to a
certain point some of them are like
really bad and you're like where you
can't beat it do they have places you
can beat them all but some of them are
just really annoying where you have no
resources you like and some of the some
of the level design requires you to
anger some of the characters you don't
want to anger and then it's just like
you could kind of sucks some some are
really easy like World 47 for those that
are Spelunky fans this one's going to
really help you out World 47 starts with
a jet pack
and
um in 4-3 when you're when you're
dropping the lava to open the secret
layer to the Queens the Queen's uh layer
to fight the turtle guy whatever his
name is there's actually on the ground
floor an escape hatch that brings you to
uh uh I don't know what you call like a
Subterranean anyway there's a there's a
level where you're supposed to die
if you're not good at the game lava
kills you and then the ank resurrects
you and then you can go through a secret
door in World 47 it's all zeros and then
47 there's actually a door you can go in
so when the lava lands you can just go
into it behind the door and then leave
so for those that are you know fans of
Spelunky chica but uh sort of yeah I
guess but it's the same world over and
over again but more importantly if
you're really good at the game you can
just not die there so like when the Lava
Falls you can just throw ropes put it
underneath one of the ledges and then
get a jet pack and fly out there's a
bunch of other ways to do it anyway
that's the game I'm playing I know too
much about it and again like I said I
don't really care for the cosmic ocean
Apex Legends but Cosmic ocean is the
second and final uh secret world in
Spelunky 2 that has 99 levels you just
skip it usually when you play well I I
usually play to it and I just don't care
like it's just so it's intense so yeah
it's a different it's a different kind
of game you're trying to pop three orbs
and then a jellyfish attacks you and I'm
just like I don't really care about that
I like the game where you're flying
around the jet pack and your shopkeepers
are fighting you and you're getting the
gold and stuff like that
anyway it's a fun game okay now that
I've wasted a lot of time talking about
that let's try and read some more Super
chats
the music and on says Tim people are
salvaging Tesla wrecks gutting them for
the batteries and motors and installing
them on old cars like BMWs with custom
firmware large market for custom
electric cars out there all right let's
do it cool let's make the mind's car
I mean yeah we'll we'll Tim cast Minds
we'll integrate it with mines so however
that can work maybe the tokens can do
something for you maybe like you can
charge it with tokens somehow something
like that like I don't know we'll figure
it out but that would be cool and then
it's like to charge it you can pay your
normal electric bill but then based on
how much charge it takes you'll like be
granted tokens or something where who
who's leading the engineering on this
car we gotta find somebody I'm gonna
find somebody all right and then we'll
just sponsor you know like the creation
of it we'll make a really Sleek video
and then maybe we'll like do an auction
for it or something one of a kind unique
car
you know with like logos on it let's do
it that'd be super cool I'm serious what
kind of car should it be
totally cool wide open on that one Luke
what do you think what do you think
Lydia it's got a gremlin it's got to be
a boss Mustang Prius
I'd like my idea better what year
Mustang uh like a 68 oh yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah hear good things that's what's
up I'm into the Mustang all right we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out do it
let's grab some super chats what is this
someone says English
let's see flag Biggums says Shaggy is a
Vietnam vet K9 unit his cowardice is
begging his friends not to get involved
he only opens up to a dog PTSD like a
mofo wow that's so sad that's horrible
that is true it's like his friends are
constantly getting in danger and he's
like guys no don't do this and you know
what's funny because he's kind of right
because every single time they do get
attacked and I'm pretty sure often these
These Guys in costumes almost do hurt
them you know pretty serious stuff
there's a lot of violence and and Benny
Hill Music too right yeah there's laugh
tracks too really yeah the old
Scooby-Doo had a lot of laugh tracks
that's cool always looking for Clues
all right don't eat that shaggy it's a
clue here's a bunch of super chats of
people wanting AI image generation
what's this one search adrenochrome I
wonder what that one is
oh I did look up made in America and
it's like Iron Maiden you typed an AI
turken flag oh made in America Raymond g
Stanley Jr says Pim tool that actually
would be a funny one he also said Luke
milkers damn right I don't know if that
would work that one's a too new of an
idea of an idea
someone said cleft the misfit Ben
Shapiro playing tennis we did that one
that was actually really funny
RJ says Ian defeats climate change with
graphene I actually referenced that in
my segment earlier today when I was
talking about euthanasia the great reset
now they want population reduction and I
pointed out that in the turn of the
century 1800s 1900s they were writing
about how horse manure would pile up in
the streets of New York and it would be
a disaster then the car was invented and
it never happened now they're saying
carbon is destroying the planet and it's
going to end the world perhaps new
technology like mining carbon from the
atmosphere to make graphene is going to
stop that
so it's like if we've done it before and
use technology to overcome these
problems why would we not do it again
and why is the Great reset the solution
it's not I think they're lying about it
because they want political power
I think their view is just like oh no we
have to do this give us all of your all
authority and bend the knee to us so we
can be in charge it's either that or
it's very short-sighted and they're not
understanding that you about the
solutions and that's also very bad and
you don't want to follow people that are
short-sighted 27 said quote the end is
Bill Nye
Tony Baloney says mark of the beast ooh
you want to type that one in let's begin
if it's good I'll search for it too type
we are change milkers but it's still
loading
Christopher says do Joe Biden sniffing
in Crossland's hair please please no
give it a couple years and then I'll be
the AI will parse me properly
which what would you want me to type in
the end isn't I the end is Bill Nye Raul
Hernandez says this one's for Lydia
always loved your input and you'll be
greatly missed Long Live chicken Ian
yeah we love chickeny and chicken Ian
will always be with you can't get rid of
him he's great marked ashamed says so
rakita Law's channel is back seems like
Google is doing the practice of blinking
channels and websites as a new form of
intimidation well that's what I was
saying it was a mass report so the AI
took him down instantly and then they
went whoops and put him back so they
said it was a mistake well I don't know
if they said it was a mistake but that
tends to be what happened how's the jury
system going at mines is it still active
yeah um because you see the AI Bill of
Rights the White House proposed and part
of it did you see it I didn't like this
last week they proposed this AI Bill of
Rights and one of the things you should
have a right to a human in these social
networks and I'm wondering if the human
rather than it because Tim was saying
it's so expensive for a person to hire
somebody so that they can admin that the
community is the person and people that
will have you available you know they've
opted in yeah yeah I mean honestly I
think that the bird Watch program at
Twitter even the the problem with it is
that it's enforcing Twitter's ridiculous
terms of service which are censorship
based but bird watching itself is
actually similar to the jury system on
mines so there are some some good things
about bird watch but it's it's enforcing
chaos like Twitter's terms are a joke I
want to answer this super Minds from
gnol dub GN old dub is that what it says
what do you think of the Tucker Carlson
interview with Kanye do you think Kanye
has any chance of becoming president who
has the best chance well okay anything
if it was great um and Kanye he's a he
says some stuff but he mentioned that 50
he said they're more black babies being
aboard than born in New York true fact
check true and that's kind of crazy
that's a terrifying concept I if you got
to look at how many are being born and
then wonder about
like the specific population reduction
targeting the black community because a
lot of these abortion clinics are in
these neighborhoods and that's that's
that's just weird and freaky
um does he have a chance of becoming
president sure but is it a big chance
probably not who has the best chance
Trump
so I mean right now Trump so I don't
know what I'll tell you
trying to be easy all right everybody
it's Friday night if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share this
show with your friends we've got a bunch
of awesome members only shows up from
this past week and from all the other
weeks you can watch the whole Library
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
and you can follow me at timcast Bill do
you want to shout anything out yeah
thanks for having me man it's great to
see you guys yeah you know you run out
of gas hit me yeah it's worth it it's
worth it yeah hit me up minds.com
ottman also you know if you're a creator
let's do the superminds thing like you
can you can earn for replying to people
we're really psyched about it I think
that it's like a new Dynamic this is
really cool because it because the the
the queries exist outside of any other
framework which means you could
incorporate these questions into any
YouTube video you do so we're going to
do an OBS plug-in too so that I don't
that so like I'll say this a shout out
to for instance like uh Jeremy over the
quartering imagine you're doing a
segment and at the end of every segment
you you say I'm gonna grab a couple
super mines it's basically funding the
production like these two super mines
were big I'm not saying every single one
is going to be big but they can help
this is a way to fund smaller channels
smaller creators uh videos and
everything if they're looking for
sponsors someone asking a question could
be a form of sponsor what percent does
mines take it's 15 which is half of
super chats but what but this is
actually a key point less than half
we're doing a commission program so
anyone so if anyone who signs up to
mines through your referral code
you get five percent of their earnings
perpetually so that comes out of our
fifteen percent oh wow so so we we if uh
a sign up comes through anyone on the
sites yours your referral code anybody's
you get five percent of their stuff
perpetual
actually you know this is a funny story
but only fans when they first started
this caused them to absolutely explode
because people
were recruiting for them because they
would get the commission fee so
commissions are super powerful yeah yeah
right on man see well thank you for
coming
um good to see you as well I have a
Minds Channel as well and I have two
words for everyone go to lucanzer.com
and uh I'm there on the Forum I'm going
to be doing an AMA there I got three
master classes exclusive videos
merchandise look uncensor.com and Linda
we will miss you thank you Luke yeah
appreciate it yeah it's bittersweet
Lydia it's been a quite a ride yeah it
has thanks for campus for coming along
or thanks for having me along with you
of course yeah happy to have you and I
uh I'll let Ian say goodbye but I had a
couple things I want to say before I go
do you have anything more to say Ian
just uh yeah yeah take care of yourself
and this world this is yours to make so
do it do your best do you want the last
word so I should I talk now
um
yeah you talk first you talk first let
Lydia talk well she talks and then I
usually say something on the way out
yeah that's fine we'll do it that way
that's fine I just want to say thank you
guys all so much you're very kind and
compassionate words I really appreciate
all your nice comments I'm not dying I'm
still gonna be around I'm still gonna be
on Twitter I'm still gonna be causing
trouble posting on Instagram doing all
this stuff
I am disappointed and it does pain me to
say that I did something that I never
thought I would have to do I started in
only fans you guys can follow me over
there at Lids of tick tock go over check
it out we already made a little video
for you and I think you guys are gonna
like it otherwise you guys can follow me
on Twitter and minds.com at Sour Patch
lights as well as Sour Patch let's dot
me Lids of tick tock tick tock so my
friends Lydia it was a couple of years
ago that I was uh posting nonsense on
Instagram and Lydia had commented
something pertaining to news which was
uh I I had noticed a couple of the
comments were insightful and then uh I
don't I don't know if it was like you I
messaged you or you messaged me or
something and then uh you started
sending me stories you thought were
interesting and I found that to be
helpful because I was producing segments
and I was like I didn't see that I
missed that one and so that actually
ended up helping me out yeah when we
decided we wanted to do some kind of
show I was like hey you know a lot of
this stuff you've you know the stories
you know the insights why don't you come
out and help us start this up and you
could be you know producing and doing
the camera stuff and so uh that was just
like almost two years ago and then you
came and joined the show since then from
the beginning and then there was another
a funny moment where
uh this is uh I don't know last year at
some point I think I saw these amazing
videos on Instagram from a rollerblader
Pacific
and he had it has a series called audio
on and it was him skating really unique
ways and I was not a rollerblader I've
been rollerblading more these days
because I just it's a blast and I saw
these clips and they were they were cool
and he's really good and so then I was
like we need to bring more action sports
people out I invited skateboarders
scooter people and then I hit him up and
I was like you want to come out and
skate and Brett knew the show and he was
like yes and they said Can my friend
come with me and I was like who's your
friend he's like Andy and I said sure
yeah Andy came out and then I meet these
two guys and they're really awesome and
I said you know uh why don't you guys
work here we'll we'll find a way to to
make this work you guys are really cool
I think you can help us out and
initially we had uh Brett filming
because we needed film for the Vlog and
Andy was doing like Grounds Maintenance
and control for like skate park stuff
and then we found out that Andy's
basically like a tech whiz security
expert with a degree in everything and I
was like okay we are drastically
underutilizing the talents of this man
and then he ends up building out this
studio and the design and all the cables
and then Brett we find out is a pop
culture genius and we're like Brett you
got to do a show Andy we said you've got
to be our CTO we need your expertise to
be able to do this and then at some
point uh Andy and Lydia fell in love and
got married and now are going off to
into the wild to have a family so I I
want to say thank you so much to you
guys for everything you know it's been
it's been an amazing ride and I hope you
guys will come back and visit and uh I
know we'll we'll make sure to shout out
the stuff that you're working on when
it's when it when it's up and running
it's been it's been absolutely amazing
and uh we have some new people who are
going to come and help us but they will
never unfortunately I'm gonna look you
in the eyes they will never
Linda Junior never be the same
can I just say before I go to that my
replacement is fantastic you guys are
really gonna love him he's an extreme
sports dude he's an international bro
he's a music Professor you guys are
gonna love him he's fantastic people are
like oh yeah big shoes to fill literally
I have big feet but it's like he is
fantastic and I think you guys are gonna
love him for sure so don't worry he's
awesome I'm leaving the show in good
hands I'm looking forward to the future
right on all right everybody thank you
all so much for everything thank you to
Andy and Lydia for everything you've
done to help make all of this possible
and and grow this company and uh we'll
see you all next time and then we'll
make sure that once you guys have
whatever show it is you're doing
whatever we can make sure we can shout
it out and everybody knows where to find
you awesome thanks bye guys